اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في حصاد الليله
وفي عناوينه
مصادر تكشف عن مقتل جندي اسرائيلي في
تبادل لاطلاق النار بمخيم جنين وعقد يومين
من عمليه عسكريه في جنين دفع فيها جيش
الاحتلال بسلاح المدرعات وقوات النخبه
والطيران اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي تعلن بدء
الانسحاب من المخيم وكتيبه جنين التابعه
لسرايا القدس تنفي وتقول انها تواصل
التصديا للعدوان المواجهات خلال اليوم
ترفع عدد الشهداء الى اثني عشر ونتنياهو
يقول ان العمليه الواسعه في جنين لن تقتصر
على جوله واحده
يتوعد بتكرارها
وفي قلبي مدينه تل ابيب عمليه دهس وطعن
تسفر عن اصابه سبعه اشخاص حماس تتبنى
العمليه وتقول انها بدايه الرد على عدوان
الاحتلال على جنين وبنك يتفقد موقع الهجوم
ويدعو جميع الاسرائيليين الى حمل السلاح
وبعد يومين من حصار المخيم ومحاولات
التوغل تحذيرات من ترد الوضع الانساني
لنحو 12 الف فلسطيني
جنود الاحتلال يطلقون الرصاص الحي على
المستشفى الحكومي بجنين ووزيره الصحه
الفلسطينيه تدين استهداف فرق الاسعاف
وعرقله الوصول الى الجرحى وحماس تقول ان
تهجير الالاف من المخيم مخطط لافراغ مناطق
الضفه لصالح الاستيطان
وفي خضم قلق دولي رافق العمليه
الاسرائيليه في جنين مجلس الامن يعقد
الجمعه مشاورات مغلقه لبحث الوضع في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه لندن تدعو تل ابيب الى
حمايه المدنيين والتراجع عن سياسه
الاستيطان برلين تؤكد على اهميه الحل
السياسي وتشدد على سلامه العاملين بالمجال
الانساني والمفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان في
الامم المتحده يطالب بوقف القتل وتدمير
الممتلكات
[موسيقى]
في اخر التطورات كشفت مصادره للجزيره عن
مقتل جندي اسرائيلي في تبادل لاطلاق النار
في مخيم جنين
وجاء ذلك بعد اعلان اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان قوات الجيش بدات بالخروج من
مخيم جنينه واظهرت صور بدا قوات من جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الانسحاب من مخيم
جنين من جهته اكد مراسل الجزيره استمرار
وجود اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه في محيط مخيم
جنين
هذا ونفد كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس
انسحاب القوات الاسرائيليه واكدت انها
مستمره في التصدي للعدوان ونقلت شبكه سي
ان ان الامريكيه عن متحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي قوله ان العمليه العسكريه في
جنين لم تنتهي بعد
وكانت القناه الثالثه عشره الاسرائيليه قد
افادت بوقوع اشتباكات مساء اليوم بين
مسلحين فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في جنين وذكرت القناه وان تلك
الاشتباكات كانت الاعنف منذ بدء العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في مخيم جنين هذا
واعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه اصابه
ثلاثه
قوات الاحتلال داخل ساحه مستشفى جنين
الحكومي ووصفت جروح اثنين منهم بالخطيره
للمره الاولى منذ بدء عمليه اقتحام جنين
دفع الجيش الاسرائيلي اليوم بسلاح
المدرعات في اليوم الثاني لعملياته
العسكريه ورصد مراسلنا تحرك مدرعات
اسرائيليه في شمال جنين انطلقت من قاعده
لوجستيه كبيره اقامها الاحتلال لدعم
اقتحامه
هذا وقالت كتائب القسام الجناح العسكري
لحركه حماس في بيان ان كما ان المقاومه
اصابت جنود الاحتلال واليته بشكل دقيق
ومباشر في ازقه المخيم من جانبه قال قائد
في كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس
للجزيره ان الكتيبه افشلت اكثر من محاوله
تقدم اسرائيليه واعطبت عددا من الاليات
والجرافات العسكريه مؤكدا ان مقاتليها
الحق خسائر كبيره بالعدو
وننوه الى هذه الصور التي تاتينا مباشره
ونحن نشاهد الان اليات ومدرعات اسرائيليه
تنسحب من مخيم جنين هذه الصور تاتينا من
شمال جنين احد المعابر في شمال جنين حيث
نرى
المدرعات
والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه وهي تخرج
من شمال جنين
ينضم الينا الياس كرام على ما اعتقد من
نفس الموقع شمال جنين من معبر الجلمه
بالتحديد حيث نشاهد هذه الاليات وهي تخرج
الياس ضعنا في سوره ما يجري على المعبر
وبكم تقدر عدد الاليات والمدرعات التي
خرجت الى حد الان
بالعشرات بالفعل فدى وهذا وهذه دفعه جديده
من الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه من
المدرعات وناقلات الجند وايضا الجرافات
العسكريه التي شاركت في عمليه اقتحام
المخيم وهي تصل الى هذا الموقع في داخل
الخط الاخضر الى المنطقه الشماليه من مخيم
جنين بالفعل هذه الدفعه الثانيه الكبيره
التي تضم عشرات الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي تنسحب من داخل المخيم
تحديدا من اطرافه الشماليه الغربيه وتتجه
عند معبر سالم في الجهه الغربيه لمدينه
جنين هنالك بطبيعه الحال معسكر لجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ويبدو ان هذه الاليات
تتجه الى هذا المعسكر نستطيع ان نؤكد بان
عدد الاليات هو كبير
وهذه الارتال العسكريه تضم جيبات عسكريه
مصفحه والعديد من
لانه من الناقلات الجند المصفحه الحديثه
التي دخلت الى حيز العمل في جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من نوع بانتير بعض هذه او احدى
الاليات هذه كانت تعرضت قبل نحو اسبوعين
الى تفجير في داخل مخيم جنين وهي كانت
تعمل وتنشط ضمن القوات العسكريه التي
توغلت في اليومين الاخيرين في داخل مخيم
جنين عدد الاليات العسكريه التي انسحبت
فيدا في الساعه الاخيره ونحن موجودون هنا
على الاطراف الشماليه لمخيم جنين تؤكد ما
كنا نشرناه اعلناه قبل نحو ساعتين عن بدء
لانسحاب القوات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه من داخل مخيم جنين وما كانت
اكدته ايضا مصادر في صحفيه اسرائيليه نقلا
عن مصادر عسكريه اسرائيليه قالت بان جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بدا بسحب قواته من
مخيم جنين لكن حتى هذه
فدا الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يعلن رسميا في
بيان رسمي بانه انسحب من داخل مخيم جنين
ولم يعلن حتى عن انتهاء عملياته العسكريه
يعني كيف يمكن تفسير ذلك نحن نشاهد
ارتال العسكريه وهي تخرج من المخيم هنالك
مصادر اعلاميه
تتحدث عن خروج او انتهاء عمليه جنين الا
ان الجيش لم يعلن ذلك بشكل رسمي الى حد
الان كيف يمكن تفسير ذلك
فدا يفسر ذلك عسكريا على اعتبار ان عمليه
الانسحاب نفسها هي عمليه لوجستيه معقده
وغايه في الخطوره تماما كعمليه الدخول
بمعنى ان هذه الارتال العسكريه عندما
تنسحب هي تكون مكشوفه ايضا للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه في داخل المخيم وبالتالي الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتكتم على عمليه الانسحاب ولا
يؤكدها بشكل رسمي حتى يتسنى لهذه القوات
الانسحاب بشكل سلس من داخل المخيم لان
عمليه الانسحاب تحيقها مخاطر ليست بسيطه
تماما كعمليه دخول وعمليه الاقتحام ومن
الناحيه اللوجستيه عمليه الانسحاب صعبه
وبحاجه الى تغطيه وغطاء عسكري وبالتالي
القوات العسكريه افدى تنسحب بشكل تدريجي
وبطبيعه الحال القوات المنسحبه هنالك من
من ظهرها من الخلف بمعنى انه ما زالت
هنالك قوات ربما تعمل وتنشط في داخل
المخيم او على الاقل في اطرافه او في بعض
المواقع المهمه من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه
لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والتي يفترض ان
يؤمنها وبالتالي قبل اتمام عمليه الانسحاب
بشكل كامل لا يبدو ان جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي سوف يعلن عن ذلك رسميا ولن
يعلن ايضا عن انتهاء عملياته العسكريه لكن
ما بامكاننا ان نؤكده في اللحظات الاخيره
من حيث عدد الاليات العسكريه التي انسحبت
فدا من الواضح بان عمليه خروج هذه الاليات
الى داخل الخط الاخضر ودخولها عبر السياج
الامني الى داخل الخط الاخضر يؤكد فعلا
على ان عمليه الانسحاب بدات بشكل كبير لكن
ربما سوف تتواصل لساعات مقبله حتى يتم جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انسحاب كافه الوحدات
وكافه الجنود الذين عملوا في داخل مخيم
اجرين عمليه الانسحاب تتم فداء من الاطراف
الشماليه للمخيم ومن الاطراف الشماليه
الغربيه له بعض القوات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه تتجه غربا نحو حاجز سالم
العسكري الموجود على الاطراف الشماليه
الغربيه لمدينه جنين وبعض القوات الاخرى
تتجه الى الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه للمخيم
عند حاجز الجلمي العسكري الواقع ايضا في
الاطراف الشماليه لمدينه جنين اذا هنالك
انسحاب على محاور عده في داخل المخيم هذا
ما نستطيع ان نؤكده الان ونشير فينا الى
ان عمليه الانسحاب كما قلت هي بخطوره في
مكان على اعتبار ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كما يبدو خسائر في عمليه
الانسحاب الاخيره واضطرت جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى استخدام الطيران الى
استخدام المصير
التي تاتينا هذه الصور لمقتل جنديا
اسرائيلي كانت مصادر قد افادت لقناه
الجزيره بانه تم قتل جندي اسرائيلي في
تبادل لاطلاق النار في مخيم جنين اذا هذه
الصور التي نشاهدها
يبدو وكانه انفجار
في رتل عسكري ننوه ايضا للعاجل الذي يظهر
على الشاشه عناصر من القسام وسرايا القدس
وشهداء الاقصى نفذوا كمينا محكما ادى الى
مقتل جنديا اسرائيلي وهذه الصور تبرز بشكل
واضح الكمين الذي استهدف رتل او استهدف
رتلا او مدرعه عسكريه وادى الى مقتل جندي
اسرائيلي
نتحول الان الى سمير ابو شماله مراسل
للجزيره من جنين سمير ما هي ملاحظاتك ونحن
نشاهد كنا منذ قليل ارتال من المدرعات
العسكريه تخرج من شمال جنين بالتحديد من
معبر الجلمه ما الذي يمكن ان تلاحظه وانت
في جنين
نعم فدا استكمالا لما تفضل به الزميل
الياس كرام بان عمليه الانسحاب قد بدات
فعليا من مخيم الجنين ومن محاور عده في
محيط المخيم ولكن الجيش الاسرائيلي على ما
يبدو ابقى بعض الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في عند احد المحاور القريبه
من مخيم جنين وبالتحديد عند شارع السينما
او دوار مفترق السينما القريب من هذا
الموقع الذي نتواجد فيه وايضا تدوره
مواجهات عنيفه بين المواطنين الفلسطينيين
وهذه القوات الاسرائيليه التي تبقت في
محيطها هذا المخيم الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا
عمليه الانسحاب فعليا في تمام الساعه
التاسعه من مساء هذا اليوم عندما تجمعت
عشرات الاليات العسكريه من خلال وصولها من
عده محاور في داخل من داخل المخيم وايضا
في محيط المخيم تجمع خلفنا مباشره ومن ثم
توجهت الى المعابر العسكريه والحواجز
العسكريه الذي اعاده انتشارها في المواقع
والسكنات العسكريه في داخل الخط الاخضر
هذه العمليه العسكريه التي هي ما زالت
متواصله مع بقاء هذه القوات التي تحيط في
مخيم جنين وهي بعض الاليات الموجوده حتى
هذه اللحظه لم تنهي العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيلي وان كانت العمليه الانسحاب قد
بدات فعليا حسب مصادر فيها الجيش
الاسرائيلي وايضا القنوات الاسرائيليه
التي بثت هذه ونقلت هذه المعلومات وهذه
المعلومات الخاصه بعمليه بدء انسحاب الجيش
من مخيم جنين ونحن نحن ايضا لاحظنا هذه
التجمعات وهذه العمليه للانسحاب من خلال
التجمعات للاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
بشكل مكثف وايضا تزامن ذلك مع عمليات
تبادل اطلاق نار بشكل كثيف وعنيف جدا خلال
عمليه الانسحاب لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه وايضا اطلاق قنابل بالدخان
باللون الابيض قنابل دخانيه في محيط هذه
الاليات والامثال العسكريه وذلك لتامين
خروج القناصين من البنايات السكنيه
المرتفعه وذلك لتامين خروج هذه الاليات
ايضا بمحاور مختلفه ولكن خلال خروج هذه
الاليات كذا المقاومه كانت تتصدى بتفجير
عبوات ناسفه شديده في الانفجار وايضا
الاشتباك المسلح مع قوات الاحتداد
الايطاليه احدى تلك العبوات الناسفه قد
استهدفت احدى الاليات المدرعه والمصفحه
وادى ذلك حسب المصادر في جيش الاسرائيلي
الى مقتل احد الجنود الاسرائيليين واصابه
اخر وقد كان هناك عمليات ايضا اصابه لجندي
بالامس اصيب بهذه العمليه العسكريه
وبالتالي هناك تبني ايضا من فصائل
فلسطينيه وتحديدا كتيبه جنين التابعه
لسرايا القدس الجناح المسلح لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي وكتاب القسام الجناح المسلح
لحركه في حماس وايضا كتائب شهداء الاقصى
التابعه لحركه فتح كلها تبنت الكثير من
عمليات تفجير العبوات الناسفه والاشتباك
مع جيش الاحتلال وايضا نصب الكمائن بشكل
مكثف لهذه القوات التي كانت تعمل خلال هذه
العمليه العسكريه في اطراف وفي بعض
الحارات والاحياء في داخل مخيم جنين الجيش
كان يتعامل بشكل
ينتقل بشكل خلال
احداث الثغرات من بيت الى بيت وذلك خلال
ديت المسح والتفتيش والتمشيط على المواقع
التي تقول السلطات الاسرائيليه بانها كانت
تبحث تبحث عن تحقيق الاهداف التي كانت
تسعى من خلالها هذه القوات الايطاليه من
البحث على المخازن الاسلحه وايضا ملاحقه
المطلوبين وهذا تم العثور على عدد من
الوسائل القتاليه والعبوات الناسفه وايضا
اعتقال عدد عشرات من الفلسطينيين
المواطنين واستجواب مئات اخرين اضافه الى
اجبار العائلات المئات العائلات
الفلسطينيه الى مغادره منازلهم وذلك كان
على ما يبدو لتفريغ هذه المناطق
والاستفراد بالمقاومين الفلسطينيين في
داخل وفي عمق مخيم جنين ولكن القوه
الفصائليه المقاومه كانت تتصدى وتصد هذه
المحاولات من قبل الجيش الاحتلال للوصول
الى العمق العمق الخاص بمخيم جنين ولكنها
فشلت في كثير من المحاولات ذكرت سمير بان
عدد من قوات الاحتلال ومدرعات لا تزال
داخل مخيم جنين في بعض الاجزاء من المخيم
هل نزل نسمع اصوات اشتباكات اطلاق نار كيف
هو الحال الان
نعم بكل تاكيد بين الحين والاخر نسمع بعض
الاصوات الناتجه عن تفجير عبوات محليه
الصنع بالاليات العسكريه وايضا القاءها
عبوات محليه وبدائيه من خلال الشبان
الفلسطينيين الذين يلقون هذه العبوات
اتجاه الدوريات العسكريه والاليات
العسكريه ويصاحب ذلك اطلاق ورد من قبل
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه الرصاص على
المواطنين الفلسطينيين بين حين واخر واخر
ايضا كان هناك تزامن مع وجود هذه الاليات
العسكريه كان هناك سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
وتحديدا باحدى المسيرات الهجوميه قد شنت
غاره الجويه على مجموعه من المسلحين في
المقبره في الحاره الشرقيه من مدينه جنين
وعدى ذلك الى اصابه عدد من الفلسطينيين
بجروح وصفت بيئه طفيفه بهذا الوقت
بالتحديد كان هناك الاعلان من قبل وزاره
الصحه الفلسطيني عن شهيد اخر قد سقط برصاص
جيش الاحتلال في احدى المواجهات مع جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبذلك وزاره الصحه قد
اعلنت عن ارتفاع حصيله الشهداء في هذه
العمليه الاسرائيليه الى اثني عشر شهيدا
وايضا كان هناك جرح اكثر من عشرين
فلسطينيا جراحه عشرين منهم وصفه بالخطيره
وتم نقل اكثر من 60 جريحا الى المستشفيات
الاخرى في المحافظات الاخرى في الضفه
الغربيه وذلك لعدم
وجود الطاقه الاستيعابيه في المستشفيات في
مخيم جنين لكثره هذه الاعداد الكبيره التي
اصيبت خلال العمليه العسكريه في مخيم جنين
شكرا لك سمير ابو شمالك كنت معنا من جنين
ننتقل الى رام الله ومدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد ونحن نشاهد هذه الاليات
لقوات الاحتلال وهي تخرج من مخيم جنين هل
نستطيع القول بان العمليه انتهت في نفس
الوقت يقول سمير بان لا تزال هنالك قوات
متابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي داخل المخيم
لا يمكن القول الا بعد ان يتاكد خروج اخر
اليه عسكريه اسرائيليه من جنين ومنطقتها
ومخيمها لانها جيش الاحتلال قد يعود او قد
تكون هذه في اطار خدعه وهذا من حق
الفلسطينيين ان يروا الامور على هذا النحو
حجم القوات التي ادخلتها ادخلها جيش
الاحتلال على جنين ومخيمها كان ضخما بشكل
لافت نحو 150 اليه متنوعه
لعديده من الويته وكتائبه واسلحته وعدد
الجنود في البدايه كان الحديث عن نحو الف
جندي يشاركونها في هذا الهجوم ثم ارتفع
العدد الى 1200 لذلك عمليه الانسحاب لن
تنتهي في فتره زمنيه قصيره وانما قد
تستغرق عده ساعات خاصه وانهم يريدون تامين
قواتهم خلال انسحابها ومعروف بانهم قد بان
جنديا قد قتل واصيب اخر في الساعه الاخيره
قبل بدء عمليه الانسحاب حيث كانت تدور
هناك اشتباكات في ثلاثه محاور شاركت فيها
قوه المقاومه المسلحه سرايا القدس وشهداء
الاقصى والقسام وغيرها وابو علي مصطفى كما
ورد في بعده مناطق مخيم جنين تحديدا يتكون
من سته احياء واهمها هو الحي الذي يقع في
قلبها حي الحواشين وهذا الحي حسب المصادر
داخل المخيم خلال المعارك نهار هذا اليوم
فان قوات الاحتلال لم تتمكن من الوصول
اليه وكانت في حيره من امرها كيف تمكن
عشرات او عادات كبيره من المقاومين
الفلسطينيين من النجاه والانسحاب الى
خارجها او الاختفاء الذين استشهدوهما
عباره عن فتيه معظمهم كانوا فتيه وكان
ثمانيه منهم قد استشهدوا من القصف الذي
قامت به الطائرات في البدايه في
الاشتباكات بعدها ما استشهد كانوا ثلاثه
من الاطفال وكان مدنيون فلسطينيون المعارك
دارت ايضا على مشارف المخيم والمواجهات
كانت في عده انحاء من مدينه جنين دوار
السينما ومنطقه مستشفى ابن سينا
وحي الهدف وغيرها لذلك الجيش الاسرائيلي
لا يبدو انه سيعلن عن انتهاء عمليته
واتمام الا بعد اتمام انسحاب قواته هي
قوات كانت دخلت الى مخيم جنين من ثلاثه
محاور المحور الرئيس كان على شارع الناصره
حاجز الجلمه المدخل الشمالي للجنين ومحور
سالم شارع حيفا المدخل الغربي لجنين
وادي برقيه شارع حاجز دوتان في المنطقه
الغربيه الجنوبيه لمنطقه جنين جميعها
تدفقت خلال يوم امس ليلا في بدايه العمليه
التي
مضى عليها تقترب من 48 ساعه الان او 45
ساعه وواضح باننا تنياهو الذي كان قد وصل
مع وزير الدفاعه الى معسكر سالم وهو معسكر
كبير ضخم للجيش الاسرائيلي غربي جنين وصل
ظنا منه مع وزير دفاعه وقال بانه اجرى
تقييما في لقاء مع قاده الجيش هناك كان
يبحث عن صوره انتصار لم يجدها وبعد ان
غادر كانت هناك اشتباكات اسفرت عن مقتل
الجندي واصابه اخر وكان هناك جندي قد اصيب
في وقت سابق بالمعارك باعتراف اسرائيلي
وكان هناك تفجير لاحدى الدوريات او
الاليات العسكريه بمعنى ان قوات الاحتلال
رغم انها دفعت بكل هذا الكم الهائل من
القوات والاليات المدرعه التي تستطيع ان
تحتل ربما بلدان بالاف الكيلومترات لم
تتمكن من ان تقوم او تحقق ماء وصفوه
باهدافها في المخيم صغير مقتظ بالسكان
لانه كانت هناك مقاومه شديده في البدايه
وكان هناك ايضا في جنين نفسها مقاومه على
عده محاور الان بانتظار ان يصدر مثل هذا
البيان فان الجيش الاسرائيلي تبقى عمليته
وكانها في احالها ما لم
يتاكد انسحاب اخر اليه عسكريه له اسرائيل
قبل ان تبدا عمليه الانسحاب ذكرت مصادر
الديوان رئاسه الوزراء بانها ابلغت
الولايات المتحده بان هذه العمليه ستنتهي
قبل ان تصل مدتها الى 48 ساعه شكرا لك يا
وليد العماري مدير مكتب الجزيره من رام
الله
قاعده لوجستيه كبيره لسلاح المدرعات شمال
جنين جهزها الجيش الاسرائيلي لتعزيز
عمليات التوغل نحو مخيم جنين فقوات
الاحتلال استخدمت تعزيزات خلال الساعات
الماضيه لاحكام الحصار التي تطبقه على
المخيم منذ بدء العمليه العسكريه عند
المدخل الشمالي تجوب اليات عسكريه للمكان
بشكل مستمر المدخل الجنوبي في شارع نابلس
بدوره تحت الرصد الكامل عبر دوريات
اسرائيليه متحركه
اما المدخل الرئيسي فيركز عنده جيش
الاحتلال قواته بوحدات راجله واليه عسكريه
كما نشر قناصه عند اسطح مباني مطله على
المكان وعند المدخل الغربي تتحصن مجموعه
من جيش الاحتلال اما في اذقه المخيم
الداخليه فالوضع الميداني اكثر تعقيدا
اللافت في تطور تحرك المقاومه اعلان كتائب
عز الدين القسام دورها الى جانب الفصائل
الاخرى وتحديدا سرايا القدس في عمليه
التصدي التطور الاهم يدور عند حي عبد الله
عزام القريب من وسط جنين مواجهه داريه
ومستمره فمحاولات جنود الاحتلال التوغل
الى قلب المخيم تواجه بمقاومه شديده يضطر
بسببها الجنود الى التنقل في الحي من داخل
المنازل بتفجير الجدران الفاصله تحاشيا
للوقوع في كمائن المق اومه والاشتباك
المباشر
حاره الدمج الواقعه عند المدخل الجنوبي
والتي تقود الى قلب المخيم ايضا تشهد
اشتباكات عنيفه وتواجه قوات الاحتلال فيها
مقاومه شرسه
يمتاز الحي بازقه ضيقه للغايه ومنازل
متلاصقه تصعب عمل الجيوش النظاميه وتكون
مهمه المقاومين اكثر سهوله
تحاول قوات الاحتلال عبر هذه المنطقه شق
طريقها الى قلب جنين وتتنقل داخل المنازل
هربا من عبوات ناسفه تتحدث معلومات ان
المقاومين زرعوها لعرقله تقدم
الاسرائيليين اما غرب المخيم فالتطورات
فيه اقل حده مقارنه بباقي الاحياء مع
اشتباكات متقطعه
فصائل المقاومه التي تتصدى للعدوان
الاسرائيلي توزع عملها في المخيم بين
وحدات تشتبك مع الجيش الاسرائيلي واخرى
تتولى مهاجمه التجمعات وتتحدث الفصائل عن
وجود وحدات هندسيه تابعه لها تقوم بمهام
رفض ومهاجمه تمركز الاليات والمدرعات
وتعمل اخرى على نشر عبوات ناسفه لمنع
التقدم اما من الجانب الاسرائيلي فتشارك
عده وحدات في حصار جنين منها
وهي وحده متخصصه في العمليات البريه
المعقده في المناطق المغلقه والغابات
والحقول مجلان وهي وحده كومندس متخصصه في
تدمير اهداف في عمق ميدان المعركه
الهندسيه وتختص في تنفيذ مهام الاقتحام
الهندسيه والهجمات التفجيريه والتخلص من
الالغام وتشغيل الروبوتات العسكريه
لواءنا حال وهو لواء مشاه نظامي شارك في
جميع الحروب الاسرائيليه منذ عام 82
تنفذ مهامها بمشاركه جنود مستعربين عوكت
وهي وحده الكلاب التي تستخدم ضمن مهام
خاصه في الجيش الاسرائيلي
انضموا الينا من عمان اللواء فايزه دويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه وفايز قوه
اسرائيليه تخرج بالياتها ومدرعاتها واخرى
تبقى كيف يمكن تقييم من الناحيه العسكريه
ما جرى في الساعات الاخيره هل هو انسحاب
يؤشر الى انتهاء العمليه ام ليس بعد
يعني يجب ابقاء الاحتمالات مفتوحه من باب
الحذر لكن اذا تحدثنا من منظور عسكري هي
مؤشرات على بدء الانسحاب لكن ما هو حجم
القوات المتبقيه وما هي طريقه فك الاشتباك
عندما نتحدث عن عمليات انسحاب من مناطق
ماهوله
وفيها كوضع مباني المخيم المتلاصقه وازقه
ضيقه وبنيه تحتيه تم تحطيمها وتهشيمها اذا
هناك اليه محدد لفك اشتباك القوات تبدا
بعمليات التخفيف من القوات التي تقع في
الخلف ومن ثم يتم تخفيف هذه القوات
تدريجيا تبقى القوات الاكثر قدره على
الحركه والاكثر قدره على الاشتباك
والانسحاب فبالتالي تاخذ وقت طويل وقت
مشروب بالحذر خوفا من الوقوع بكماء وبنفس
الوقت يجب ان تبقي كما يقال لها قدم على
الارض لمعاوده النشاط العسكري مره اخرى
اذا اقتضت الضروره اذا المعلومات العامه
تشير الى بدايه التخفيف ومن ثم هي مراحل
في الانسحاب لكن يجب ان ياخذ مقتدى وقد
يمتد لساعات قادمه واضح بانها مراحل معقده
ما هي الصعوبات التي يمكن ان تعتري عمليه
الانسحاب ونحن شاهدنا منذ قليل استهداف
مدرعه اسرائيليه ومقتل جندي اسرائيلي
يعني هذه هي احد اهم واخطر الامور ان تتم
هناك تنفيذ هجمات الان عندما نتحدث عن
كتيبه جنين وبقيه
المقاتلين نتحدث عن شباب لديهم لياقه
بدنيه هناك توزيع للادوار متقن بدءا من
المراقبه الى جماعات القنص الى جماعات رد
الفعل السريع والاغاره وبالتالي هذه تعتبر
الوقت المثالي
للقوات لشباب المقاومه للانقضاض على
القوات المنسحبه لان القوات المساحبه مهما
احتاطت لابد ان تعطي كما يقال ظهرها
للمنطقه التي كانت تتواجد بها وهنا تكون
فرصه المقاتلين الان عمليه التفجير
والكمين الذي حدث ومقتل جندي اسرائيلي
واصابه اخر هي تشير ب وضوح الى درجه الوعي
والنضج لدى الشباب المقاتلين الذين اولا
حالوا دون دخول القوات الاسرائيليه
الكبيره الى عمق المخيم واستطاعوا
بامكانات محدوده جدا ان يلحقوا بعض
الخسائر قد لا تكون بالحجم المطلوب قد لا
تكون بالحجم الذي يتمناه المقاتل ولكن
السؤال الاخضر هل نجحت العمليه من وجهه
نظر عسكريه انا هنا لا اتحدث عن الدمار
وعن الجرافات وما شابه ذلك ما هو الذي
يقرر النجاح او الفشل هو طبيعه الهدف ما
هو الهدف الهدف على لسان وزير الدفاع
ورئيس الوزراء وبني جفير وسموترش وغيره
القضاء على المقاومه السؤال المطروح هل
حققت العمليه هذا الهدف الايجابي قطعا لا
اذا العمليه من نظر عسكريه وتقييم عسكري
فاشله بامتياز هنا رغم اهميه ما احدث من
دمار رغم اهميه الاسلام لكن ما هو المحدد
الذي
يعني يوضح بشكل واضح ان كانت عمليه ما
نجحت ام لا الجانب الاسرائيلي يقول بانه
دمر البنيه التحتيه العسكريه وانه دمر
معامل لصدع المتفجرات وانه اعتقل عدد كبير
من من يصفهم بالارهابيين كيف يمكن ضحك ذلك
من خلال ما نراه على الارض
الان الهدف من العمليه القاء القبض او
تصفيه المقاتلين ما هي اعداد المقاتلين
الذين تم القاء القبض عليهم لا نتحدث عن
الرقم الذي التي تحدثت عنه اسرائيل هؤلاء
قد لا يكون جزء من التنظيم المقاتل شباب
المقاومه منذ اللحظه الاولى انكفا الى
الداخل واصبح من الصعب الوصول لهم اذا
بمعنى اخر العناصر المقاتله في كتيبه جدين
وبقيه الفصائل لا يزال موجودين لم يتم
الحديث قد يتبين لاحقا انهم تمكنوا من
القاء القبض على بعض الافراد لكن بصوره
عامه لا يوجد حديث عن قتلى من المقاتلين
لا يوجد حديث عن اسر لعناصر من المقاومه
الان نتحدث في جانب اخر اذا هنا اعود
واقول الهدف محدد هل تم تحقيق الهدف
الاجابه حتى اللحظه التي يتحدث فيها قطعا
لا اذا من وجهه تقييم نظر عسكري انا اعتبر
ان العمليه فاشله بامتياز قد تكون مكلفه
من حيث البنيه التحتيه قد تكون مكلفه من
حيث تهجير 4000 قد تكون مكلفه من حيث
تدبير شبكه المجاري الى غير ذلك لكن
السؤال هل تحقق الهدف الايجابي لا ما دام
العنصر المقاتل قد نجا من هذا من هذا
الكمين وهذه العمليه اذا شراره المقاومه
لا زالت موجوده عنصر المقاومه لازال موجود
وهذا ما اوضحه نتناهم عندما قال لن تكون
هي المره الاخيره قد يكون هناك مرات اخرى
واقتحامات اخرى هذا اشاره الى فشل العمليه
هكذا افهم تصريح نتنياهو العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه كنت معنا من عمان
وفي تل ابيب اصيب سبعه اشخاص بعمليه دهس
وطعن نفذها شاب فلسطيني وافاد شهود عيان
ان منفذ العمليه كان يقود سياره بسرعه
فائقه والصدم بقوه بمحطه لتوقف الحافلات
وبعدها ترجل وقام بطعن اسرائيليين قبل ان
يقوم حارس امن باطلاق النار عليه من قريبه
وقد اظهر مقطع فيديو ان منافذ العمليه كان
يرتدي بنطالا عسكريا وقامت قوات الشرطه
الاسرائيليه بتطويق مسرح العمليه وتمشيط
المنطقه هذا وتبنت حركه حماس عمليه تل
ابيب ونعت منفذها عبد الوهاب خلايله واكدت
حماس ان هذه العمليه هي بدايه الرد على
عدوان الاحتلال على جنين
ومن موقع عمليه تل ابيب دع وزير الامن
الاسرائيلي اعتماد جميع الاسرائيليين الى
حمل السلاح حسب ما نقلت صحيفه معاريف وقال
بنكفير الذي زار موقع العمليه انه هجومه
تل ابيب يثبت مره اخرى اهميته وفعاليه
المواطنين الذين يحملون السلاح ونقلت
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان بنكفير قبل لدى
وصوله للموقع بترديد هتافات من جانب
اسرائيليين طالبوه بتوفير الامن بينما
وصفه بعضهم بالعنصريه الارهابي
ينضم الينا من رام الله الدكتور غسان
الخطيب استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
بيرزيت دكتور غسان بينما كانت قوات
الاحتلال تقوم بعمليتها في جنين عمليه في
تل ابيب يقوم بها شاب فلسطيني الى ماذا
يؤشر ذلك
ما كان الجميع يتوقع ان هذه العمليه
العدوانيه الاسرائيليه على مخيم جنين من
ناحيه لن تنجح بتحقيق اهدافها لا السياسيه
ولا العسكريه لانه بعد انتهاء هذه العمليه
اجلا ام عاجلا سوف تعود الامور في مخيم
جنين الى ما كانت عليه
وسيعود الدور الكفاحي والدور المقاوم
لمخيم جنين مثل ما كان عليه لا بل اكثر من
ذلك سيكون هناك يعني ارتفاع في التاييد
الشعبي وفي اقبال الشباب على هذا النوع من
النشاط الوطني المقاوم ومن ناحيه اخرى
ستؤدي هذه العمليه العدوانيه على مخيم
جنين الى ازدياد ردود الفعل
الانتقاميه المقاومه من جانب جهه مختلفه
وشباب مختلفين من مناطق وفي اماكن مختلفه
من ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني الذي يشعر انه
الان يد واحده في مواجهه هذا العدوان
لاحظنا اليوم مظاهر تحركات شعبيه في كافه
المدن والمخيمات والقرى الفلسطينيه تضامنا
مع جنين للتعبير على وحده الشعب الفلسطيني
الكفاحيه
اتوقع ان يكون هناك عمليات عديده مشابهه
كردود فعل للعدوان الاسرائيلي الجانب
الاسرائيلي وعلى لسان رئيس الحكومه يقول
ان هذه العمليه لن تكون الوحيده بل يبدو
ان هنالك نهجا واضحا سيتكرر بشكل متسارع
في الاوقات او في الايام المقبله وهو
القيام بعمليات تكون تكبر او تصغر حسب
الحاجه ولكن بشكل متكرر بحسب ما قاله
نتنياهو اذا كيف يمكن الرد على ذلك او على
الاقل التحضير للرد عليه من قبل الجانب
الفلسطيني
هذا صحيح تماما ومتوقع تماما ولا يمتلك
نتنياهو غير الاستمرار في مثل هذه
الاعتداءات اولا لانه الحاله الثوريه في
الضفه الغربيه تشكل تحدي كبير ميداني
وسياسي
لنتنياهو وحكومته هذه الحكومه التي جاءت
على ارضيه محاوله حسم الصراع على الارض في
الضفه الغربيه واذ بها تواجه تصاعد
للمقاومه وتصاعد للحاله الوطنيه والحاله
الثوريه والحاله الشعبيه المقاومه
للاحتلال اذا هو في حاله حرج سياسي داخلي
وفي حاله حرج امني الامر الذي سوف يدفعه
الى مزيد من مثل هذه الاعتدادات وهذا في
الحقيقه يشكل تحدي
الشعب الفلسطيني ويقتضي من الشعب
الفلسطيني ان يكون مستعدا وجاهزا لاستمرار
هذه المواجهات وهذا يجب ان يؤدي الى يعني
جهود نحو توحيد الصف الفلسطيني الذي يعاني
كما هو معروف من عوامل ضعف عديده من اهمها
حاله يعني الانقسام التي يعيشها
تعيشها الساحه السياسيه الفلسطينيه التحدي
كبير ويتطلب جهود متغافره وموحده من جميع
اطياف السياسيه للشعب الفلسطيني خصوصا
وانه الظروف عفوا شكرا لك دكتور غسان
الخطيب استاذ علوم السياسيه في جامعه
بيرزيت كنت معنا من رام الله
في تفاصيل اليوم الثاني من العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في جنين كان مشهد
الاوضاع الانسانيه
فقوه الاحتلال تواجه اتهامات بتهجير الاف
من سكانها اما من كانوا محاصرين اما من
كانوا محاصرين داخل جنين فواجهوا نقصا في
المواد الغذائيه وانقطاعا للخدمات
تستحضر هذه الصور لسكان مخيم جنين مشاهد
الاباء والاجداد زمن النكبه الفلسطينيه
عام 48 اخرج هؤلاء من بيوتهم عنوه على يدي
جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي خلال عمليته
العسكريه على المخيم للكثافه الاكبر من
بين مخيمات الضفه الغربيه فاصبح اللاجئون
مهجرين مره اخرى استنادا الى رئيس بلديه
جنين فان مجموعه ما هجره الجيش الاسرائيلي
بلغ حتى الان نحو اربعه الاف فلسطيني وانه
يحاصر قرابه ثلاثه عشر الفا داخل المخيم
ثم شرع الجيش الاسرائيلي بتجريف المنازل
او تخريبها او تحويلها لمقر عسكريه مؤقته
كما حول بعضها الى نقاط عبور لجنوده عبر
فتح ثغرات في الجدران بهدف تنقلهم من
منطقه الى اخرى والوصول الى قلب المخيم
حيث يتحصل مقاومون فلسطينيون هناك اما من
بقي من سكان مخيم جنين فليسوا بافضل حالا
فهذه البقعه الصغيره المكتظه بالسكان
شهدت كل اشكال الحرب ودمرت شبكه الكهرباء
والمياه وفق المنسقه الامميه للشؤون
الانسانيه وعلاوه على ذلك منعت الطواقيم
الطبيه من الوصول الى من يحتاجها واعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه اعتقل نحو 120 شخصا
تعلن وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه بدا انسحاب
الجيش الاسرائيلي من المخيم وكان رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو قال
ان الاقتحام او الهجوم سيتكرر مدام ذلك
ضروريا للقضاء على ما يصفه بالارهاب وان
جنين لن تعود مجال له
لكن ما حدث في المخيم من تهجير وهدم
لمنازل المدنيين يثير اسئله تشير الى نقطه
ابعد من الوقوف عند عمليه عسكريه امنيه
فنتنياهو نفسه وقبل ايام صرح بالضروره
العمل على اجتثاف فكره اقامه الدوله
الفلسطينيه يضاف الى ذلك ما اقرته الحكومه
الاسرائيليه مؤخرا من تسهيل اجراءات
التوسع الاستيطاني في كل ارجاء الضفه
الغربيه
وفي مقابله هاتفيه مع الجزيره تحدثت
المواطنه الفلسطينيه تهاني جمال وهي احدى
من اجبروا على الخروج من منازلهم في جنين
عن مداهمه القوات الاسرائيليه لمنزلها
والمنازل المجاوره واجبارها واسرتها على
الخروج من المنزل بعد اطلاق النار على
ابنها
مباشره على البيوت
على البيوت حاولوا يدخلوا على البيوت من
بيت لبيت
انهم يفتحوا فتحات في البيوت حتى ما وصلوا
بيتنا وكل بيت يفوت عليه يحكوا انه ليش
انتم بعدكم مش طالعين من البيوت احنا
بلغنا فيه اجتياح حكينا لهم انه احنا هاي
بيوتنا اخذوا طلعوها على بيت الجيران على
من بيت لبيت مكلفه حيقولوا انك تطلع
الطريق انشيها انا اطلع من البيت على اساس
انه
خلوه في مغترب
ول
نار
فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العامه
للامم المتحده سيد فرحان يعني تهجير اكثر
من اربعه الاف شخص عدم فتح ممرات انسانيه
استهداف طواقم الاسعاف استهداف المخيم
بسلاح الجو تجريف المخيم والامم المتحده
تعرف عن قلقها هل يبدو موقف الامم المتحده
متناسبا مع من يجري على الارض
يمكن ان تقوم به الامم المتحده هو ان
تتاكد من ان كل العمليات
التي تتم تحترم القانون الانساني الدولي
عبرنا عن قلقنا ايذاء كيفيه التعامل في
هذه العمليه وان منظمه الاونروا تعمل في
عشره مواقع في مخيم جنين واربعه من
المدارس يوم امس هو مركز صحي لم يتمكنوا
من العمل بسبب تبادل الكثيف لاطلاق النار
لذلك من الاهميه بما كان ان كل الجهود
تعمل بالاضافه الى
المباني التي تقدم الرعايه الصحيه والناس
يمكنهم الوصول الى الرعايه الصحيه نحن نصر
على ذلك المفاوض السامه لحقوق الانسان عبر
عن قلقه الب الغ ازاءه ما يحصل في جنين
والامين العام مجددا دعها الى احترام
القانون الانساني الدولي ان نتاكد من
احترام القانون احترام القانون الانساني
الدولي سيد فرحان حق
في الحقيقه نحن نرى ان العمليات تستمر
ونحن في
حوارنا لكي نرى ما الذي يمكن القيام به
للتوقف هذه العمليات وسوف نرى سوف تاتي به
ساعه المقبله لكن
سيد لم يكن هذا هو سؤالي مفوض الامم
المتحده السامه لحقوق الانسان قال ان
استخدام الغارات الجويه لا يتصق مع
القواعد المطبقه في اساليب عمليات انفاذ
القانون تلك الغارات الجويه قد تعد قتلا
متعمدا
نعم
والقلق الذي لدينا هو ان اي هجمات تتم في
مكان مقتظ
بالسكان واذاه كثافه كثافه سكانيه عاليه
يؤدي الى مخاطر مرتفعه وضحايا في المدنيين
وهناك عدد كبير من الناس الذين هم بحاجه
الى رعايه صحيه وخدمات طبيه وهناك مشاكل
بتقديم الرعايه الصحيه لهم كل ذلك يجب ان
يتغير ويجب ان اتاكد من عدم وجود هجمات
اضافيه في اماكن تركز السكان
ما هي الاليات التي تعتمدون من اجل ان
تتاكدوا
نحن نتواصل مع كل الفرقاء المعنيين ونحن
نتواصل مع الحكومات
وكلهم بما في ذلك
الدول في مجلس الامن الجميع يعرف ما هو
الوضع واذا ما برزت الحاجه الى المتابعه
يعرفون ما يجب القيام به سيد فرحان انه
هناك ما يقارن بمواقف الامم المتحده
والمجتمع الدولي فيما يتعلق بما يجري
باوكرانيا وما يجري في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله الا يبدو موقف الامم المتحده
وكانه يكيل بمكيالين في هذا الاطار
هلا ليس بالنسبه الى ما يحصل ولدينا معيار
واضح ذكرتم اوكرانيا النقطه الاساسيه هي
انه سواء كنا نتحدث عن اوكرانيا او عن
مكان مثل جنين نود ان نتاكد من ان كل
الهجمات التي تستهدف البنى التحتيه
المدنيه تتوقف والاماكن التي فيها اقتضاض
كبير للسكان تكون امنه من اي هجمات وهذا
المعيار يطبق في كل مكان يجب ان يطبق في
كل مكان يجب وقف الضحايا في اوساط
المدنيين اينما كانوا ولكن سيد فرحان هذا
لم يتحقق ما تقولونه لانه لم يتم فتح
ممرات امنه فرق الاسعاف تقول بانها تتعرض
لاستهداف مباشر ولا يسمح لها بالدخول
بالتالي ماذا انتم فاعلون
نحن نتواصل مع نظرائنا بما في ذلك
الحكومه الاسرائيليه للتاكد من ان هذا
الامور سوف تتم اي انه يكون لدينا عمليات
انسانيه مستمره نحن نصر على ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه لمن هم بحاجه
شكرا لك سيد فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه انها تتابع
بقلق بالغ الوضع في اسرائيل والاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله ودعت الى مراعاه مبدا
التناسب بموجب القانون الدولي خلال
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه في مخيم
جنين للاجئين كما دعت الى حمايه المدنيين
كاولويه قصوى والى ضمان الوصول المناسب
للعاملين في المجال الانساني في المخيم
اضافت الخارجيه الالمانيه ان كل من يتحمل
المسؤوليه في هذا الوضع عليه ان يبذل الان
قصار جهده لتهدئه الوضع الامني المتوتر
ومنع المزيد من العنف وقالت ايضا انه دون
حل سياسي للنزاع لن يكون من الممكن معالجه
اسباب العنف
قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريتشى سوناك
انه يؤيد حقائق اسرائيل في الدفاع عن
نفسها وانه دانما وصفه بالعمليات
الارهابيه الاخيره كما حث الجيش
الاسرائيلي على ضبط النفس واضافه هناك ان
حمايه المدنيين يجب ان تكون اولويه وقال
انه اوضح مرارا لاسرائيل معارضه بلاده لاي
توسع استيطاني وانه طلب منها التراجع عن
سياساتها في هذا الشان لان المستوطنات
تتعارض مع القانون الدولي وعقبه في طريق
السلام وتهدد امكانيه حل الدولتين
وضع المفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان في الامم
المتحده فولكر ترك الى وقف القتل وتدمير
الممتلكات في جنين وقالتورك انه يجب على
القوات الاسرائيليه ضمان وصول كل المصابين
الى الرعايه الطبيه كما دعا المفوض الاممي
السامي لحقوق الانسان القوات الاسرائيليه
الى ضمان وصول كل المصابين الى الرعايه
الطبيه
والفتاتورك الى ان وفيات المدنيين الناجمه
عن العمليه الاسرائيليه قد ترقى الى القتل
العمده
ينضم الينا من لندن جيرمي كوربن النائب
المستقل في البرلمان البريطاني والزعيم
السابق لحزب العمال البريطاني سيد الجيرمي
كيف
تقيمون موقف بريطانيا فيما يتعلق بما يجري
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
في الحقيقه في الليله الماضيه الحكومه
البريطانيه قدمت امام البرلمان مشروع
قانون بشكل اساسي يعارض اي انشطه
لحركه المقاطعه لاسرائيل والعقوبات على
اسرائيل بشكل اساسي القانون يلحظ ان
السلطات المحليه لا يمكنها ان تشارك باي
انشطه مرتبطه
بالاراضي المحتله وبعد ذلك قالت الحكومه
عن حق ان
المستوطنات غير قانونيه ولكن ما من
اجراءات عمليه بالنسبه الى ذلك وبالتالي
نتحدث عن توسعا في
الاستيطان والحركه الاستيطانيه وهناك ايضا
600 حاجز تفتيش ونقطه تفتيش في الضفه
الغربيه هذا وضع لا يطاق بالنسبه الى
الشعب الفلسطيني واودو ان المزيد اكثر من
الاذنات من الحكومات الغربيه تدين هذا
الاحتلال غير القانوني طيب ما هي الادوات
التي يمتلكها الجانب البريطاني للضغط على
الجانب الاسرائيلي ان اراد ريتشوناك رئيس
الحكومه البريطانيه يقول بان المستوطنات
تقوت حل الدولتين وانه طلب من اسرائيل
توقف عن توسيع الاستيطان الا ان ذلك يبقى
كلاما هل من ادوات تمتلكها الحكومه
البريطانيه للضغط على اسرائيل
انت على حق فيما تفضلت به هذه عباره عن
كلمات مجرد كلمه لسنوات طويله ادانا
متكرره للحركه الاستيانيه غير ان الارقام
من فكت تزداد وهناك خطط لتوسيع المستوطنات
ان الادوات يمكن ان تكون قانونيه وفقا
للقوانين الدوليه واسرائيل وجدت انها خرقت
اتفاقيه جناف والقوانين الدوليه فيما تقوم
به في الضفه الغربيه ولكن بالنسبه الى فرض
على اسرائيل او عدم فرض اي قانون على
اسرائيل يعني ان اسرائيل لا تشعر باي ضغط
من اي دوله غربيه واي دوله في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وهي في المقابل لتستمر بالحصول
على سعادات وعلى تسليح من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ومن دول اخرى وهذا يعقد
العمليه عمليه السلام اذا ما كان هناك من
عمليه سلام سوف تتطلب من اسرائيل وقف
الحركه الاستيطانيه والانسحاب من الضفه
الغربيه ولكن الان هناك اكثر من نصف مليون
مستوطن في الضفه الغربيه وهذا الرقم مرشح
للارتفاع وما يحصل في جنين هو نتيجه هذه
السياسه وبالتالي في غياب الضغط الاقتصادي
الحقيقي على اسرائيل من وخفض في تقديم
الاسلحه لاسرائيل ما حصل وما نراه في جنين
سوف يتكرر وان غضب الشعب الفلسطيني سوف
يستمر ويوم غد سوف يكون هناك مظاهره امام
السفاره الاسرائيليه في لندن حول المسائل
التي تحصل في ليست المره الاولى ولا اعتقد
انها المره الاخيره
يعني ما الذي يمنع هذا الضغط ما الذي
تخشاه الدول الاوروبيه ما الذي تخشاه
بريطانيا لماذا يبدو وانها لا تريد ان
تضغط
هذه الدول
لطالما اطرت كل الامور حول امن اسرائيل
ووجود دوله اسرائيل ان منظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه تعترف وتقر بوجود دوله اسرائيل
والمفاوضات تحاول ان تفاوض او تتفاوض مع
دوله اسرائيل وبالتالي ليست هذه المساله
بالنسبه اليك هذه الدول تؤطر المشكله
بالزاويه الامنيه وذلك بسبب الهجمات التي
تستهدف اسرائيل طبعا انا لا اود اي هجمات
صاروخيه ولا اود اي هجمات من اي طرف ولكن
الدعم المستمر لاسرائيل يؤدي الى مفاقمه
الوضع
والا في حال وجد الضغط الحقيقي على
اسرائيل من قبل المتحده الامريكيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي بالاضافه الى اخذ
المجال الاقتصادي والعسكري
بعين الاعتبار لا ارى اي تغيير
اداره اوباما حاولت ان توقف الحركه
الاستطانيه لفتره لفتره وجيزه ادى ذلك الى
نتيجه ايجابيه ولكن بعد ذلك توقف الامر
اعتبر اقر
بالقدس عاصمه لاسرائيل وذلك على عكس
الاتفاقيات السابق وهذا ادى الى مفاقمه
الوضع
ودوله تحتل دوله اخرى هذا فعل خاطئ هو
خاطئ في حاله روسيا واوكرانيا والامر
السيان بالنسبه الى احتلال اسرائيل
للضفه الغربيه
ومحاصره عمليه لقطاع غزه ان
حق
الفلسطينيين سوف يستمر الشعب الفلسطيني
بالمطالبه به والرد من اسرائيل ياتي بقصف
مخيم من مثل جنين نحن تحدثوا عن مخيم مقتض
شكرا لك سيد جريمه انا ابن مستقل في
البرلمان البريطاني والزعيم السابق لحزب
العمال البريطاني كنت معنا من لندن
مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه للتطورات في
جنين وفي العناوين
مقتلوا جندي اسرائيلي واصابه اخر في كمين
نفذه عناصر من القسام وسرايا القدس وشهداء
الاقصى في جنين اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
تعلن بدء انسحاب القوات العسكريه من
المنطقه وكتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس
تنفي وتقول انها تواصل التصديا للعدوان
عقب يومين من بدء العمليه العسكريه عدد
الشهداء يرتفع الى 12 والجرحى يتجاوز
المئه ونتنياهو يقول ان العمليه لن تقتصر
على جوله واحده
مدينه تل ابيب هي تدعس وطعن تسفر عن اصابه
سبعه اشخاص حماس تتبنى العمليه وتقول انها
بدايه الرد على عدوان الاحتلال على جنين
وبنكفير يتفقد موقع الهجوم ويدعو جميع
الاسرائيليين الى حمل السلاح
وبعد يومين من حصار المخيم ومحاولات
التوغل تحذيرات من ترد الوضع الانساني
لنحو 12 الف فلسطيني
جنود الاحتلال يطلقون الرصاص الحي على
المستشفى الحكومي بجنين ووزيره الصحه
الفلسطينيه تدين استهداف فرق الاسعاف
وعرقله الوصول الى الجرحى وحماس تقول ان
تهجير الالاف من المخيم مخطط لافراغ مناطق
الضفه لصالح الاستيطان
وفي خضم قلق دولي رافق العمليه
الاسرائيليه في جنين مجلس الامن يعقد
الجمعه مشاورات مغلقه لبحث الوضع في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه لندن تدعو تل ابيب الى
حمايه المدنيين وتراجع عن سياسه الاستيطان
برلين تؤكد على اهميه الحل السياسي وتشدد
على سلامه العاملين بالمجال الانساني
والمفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان في الامم
المتحده يطالب بوقف القتل وتدمير
الممتلكات
[موسيقى]
في اخر التطورات افادت مصادر للجزيره بان
عناصر من القسام وسرايا القدس وشهداء
الاقصى نفذوا كمينا محكما ادى الى مقتل
جندي اسرائيلي واصابته اخر واظهرت صور
استهداف المقاومه داخل مخيم جنين لاليه
عسكريه اسرائيليه بعبوه ناسفه وقالت كتائب
القسام بالضفه الغربيه في بيان انها تواصل
الاشتباك من مسافه صفر مع جيش الاحتلال
داخل ازقه مخيم جنين واكدته وقوع اصابات
واضافت ان عناصرها خاضت اشتباكات عنيفه
وفجرت عبوات ناسفه فعاليات جيش الاحتلال
في مدينه جنين
جاء ذلك بعد اعلان اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان قوات الجيش بدات بالخروج من مخيم جنين
واظهرت صور بدء قوات من جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الانسحاب من مخيم جنين من
جهتها اكد او من جهته اكد مراسل الجزيره
استمرار وجود اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه في
محيط المخيم
[موسيقى]
هذا ونفذت كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا
القدس انسحاب القوات الاسرائيليه واكدت
انها مستمره نفت هذا الانسحاب واكدت انها
مستمره في التصدي للعدوان ونقلت شبكه سي
ان ان الامريكيه عن متحدثا باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي قوله ان العمليه العسكريه في
جنين لم تنتهي بعد
قال مراسل الجزيره ان عددا من الفلسطينيين
اصيبوا بجروح النتيجه غاره اسرائيليه
استهدفت موقعا داخل مقبره في الحي الشرقي
بجنين وذكر الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الخليه
المستهدفه شكلت تهديدا على قواته في جنين
في هذه الاثناء اعلنت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه ارتفاع عدد الشهداء جراء
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه في جنين
ومخيمها الى 12 وذلك بعد العثور على جثمان
شهيد بشارع حيفا في جنين في حين بلغ عدد
الجرح نحو 100 بينهم عشرون في حاله خطره
كما اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اعتقال 120
فلسطينيا خلال العمليه العسكريه في جنين
تنضم الينا شبكه مراسلين من جنين مراسل
جزيره سمير ابو شماله من رام الله مدير
مكتب الجزيره وليد العمري ومن شمال جنين
مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام الياس نبدا معك
ونتابع معك خروج الاليات العسكريه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من مخيم جنين في
الساعه السابقه كنت قد اشرت الى خروج عدد
من الارتال والاليات هل هذه العمليه لا
تزال مستمره
هي توقفت فداء على الاقل في الساعه
الاخيره منذ اخر ظهور لنا عبر شاشه
الجزيره حيث كنا قد رصدنا على الاقل ثلاثه
ارتال عسكريه اسرائيليه تضم عشرات الاليات
العسكريه بالاضافه الى الجرافات التي
انسحبت من المناطق الشماليه الشرقيه
والشماليه الغربيه لمخيم جنين لكن منذ
ساعه من الان تقريبا عمليه الانسحاب توقفت
تماما ولم نعد نرى على الاقل من الموقع
الذي يوجد فيه حاليا اي انسحاب للقوات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه عدا عن ذلك على
العكس نحن راينا ان هنالك بعض ناقلات
الجند على الاقل ثلاث نقلات جند دخلت من
هذا المكان الى داخل المناطق الشماليه
لمخيم جنين تحديدا او الشماليه الغربيه
ربما في محاوله لنقل مزيد من الجنود على
متن هذه المدرعات لكن حاليا عمليه انسحاب
متوقفه وعندما يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي بان
عملياته لم تستكمل بعد او لم تنتهي بعد في
داخل مخيم جنين هذا يؤكد حقيقه وجود عديد
الاليات العسكريه وعديد الجنود
الاسرائيليين الذين ما زالوا موجودين في
داخل المخيم وبطبيعه الحال فداء عمليه
الانسحاب ذاتها وهي تتم عمليا بشكل تدريجي
وبشكل بطيء هذه عمليه الانسحاب هي جزء لا
يتجزا من العمليه العسكريه واحيانا
الانسحاب يكون اخطر من عمليات الدخول ومن
عمليه التوغل ومن بدايه هذه العمليه لذلك
عمليه الانسحاب هي عمليه لا يستهان بها من
المنظور العسكري وهي خطيره بمكان على
اعتبار انها تعرض القوات المنسحبه ربما
الى كنائن قد يكون المسلحون الفلسطينيون
قد نصبوها لهم وقد راينا في ساعات عصرا
هذا اليوم كيف ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي كانت يبدو انها كانت
تستعد للانسحاب من مخيم جنين كيف انها
اشتبكت مع خلايا مسلحه تابعه للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه وهو ما استدعى جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كما يقول الى تفعيل احدى
المسيرات الهجوميه التي استهدفت هذه
الخليه على اعتبار ان كان هنالك خطر مقدق
بهذه القوات المنسحبه من مخيم جنين
وبالتالي الان لا يمكن الحديث رسميا على
الاقل من وجهه نظري جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على الانسحاب كامل من المخيم
لا يوجد اي بيان رسمي من جانب الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن ذلك ولا يوجد اي بيان
اخر يتحدث عن انتهاء العمليات العسكريه في
داخل المخيم وكما يبدو بان العديد من
القوات العسكريه الاسرائيليه ما زالت
تتمركز على اطراف مخيم جنين في الناحيه
الشماليه الشماليه الغربيه والشماليه
الشرقيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي
انسحبت في الساعه الاخيره كانت تتجه
باتجاه معسكري سالم في الجهه الغربيه
للمنطقه الحدوديه او الشريط الامني وكذلك
في الجهه الشرقيه نحو معبر الجليمي الواقع
في الاطراف الشماليه الشرقيه لمدينه جنين
وبالتالي عمليه الانسحاب ان كانت ستستكمل
من وجهه نظري جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
فانها سوف تحتاج ربما لساعات كثيره قادمه
وقد تستكمل مع ربما الساعات الاولى من
صباح هذا اليوم ابقى معنا الياسه انتقل
اليك سمير سمير عمليه الانسحاب هذه التي
كنا قد شاهدناها خلال الساعه الاولى من
الحصاد كيف انعكست على الارض هل تبدل
الحال
نعم بكل تاكيد تبدل الحال نحن نتحدث عن
انسحاب كامل لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
حيث الان انا اتواجد في الشارع وهو شارع
السينما الذي كان قد شهد خلال الساعه
الماضيه
مواجهات عنيفه مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه التي
بقيت في بعض الاليات في هذا المفترق الذي
يجاور
جنين وايضا كان هناك هذه المواجهات تندلع
عند هذا المفرق فيها الشاشه
في داخل مخيم جنين هناك الكثير من
المواطنين قد بداوا بالنزول والخروج من
منازلهم وايضا الدخول الى هذا المخيم
وتفقد حجم الدمار الهائل جدا الذي خلفته
العمليه العسكريه والاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن انسحاب
من مخ الجنين بعد خروج الاليات التي تبقت
في هذا
مفترق بالتحديد وايضا دخول المواطنين
والحركه التي بدات تنتعش بشيئا فشيئا في
هذا الشارع وهو احد الشوارع الحيويه في
داخل مدينه جنين والمؤديه الى المخيم
وبالتالي هناك ايضا طواقم الدفاع المدني
وطواقب البلديه وغيرها من المؤسسات
المحليه والاشغال التي تعمل وتحاول البحث
عن مخلفات لجيش الاحتلال قبل ان يكون هناك
جماهير من المواطنين في داخل المخيم خشيه
من المخلفات التي ربما قد يكون جيش
الاحتلال قد تركها خلفه خلال هذه العمليه
العسكريه وايضا حاله الدمار الهائل الذي
شهدته وايضا
شوهدت على بعض مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لحجم الدمار الموجود في هذا هذا المخيم
خلال
فيها تدمير من قبل الجيش الاحتلال
والجرافات التي استخدمت في هذه العمليه
العسكريه نحن نتحدث عن جرافات مصفحه كانت
تعمل بتدمير البنى التحتيه لشبكات المياه
والكهرباء وايضا تجريف العديد من الازقه
والشوارع وايضا هدم بعض الاسوار الخاصه
ببعض الممتلكات الخاصه بمن منازل
الفلسطينيين وهذه الاسوار التي تم هدمها
خلال دخول القوات الايطاليه وايضا تمهيد
الطرق للاليات لدخول في عمق او محاولات
الدخول الى عمق هذا المخيم نحن نتحدث في
هذه العمليه العسكريه حتى هذه اللحظه
نتحدث حسب وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه قد
اسفرت عن استشهاده اثني عشره فلسطينيا
برصاص جيش الاحتلال وفي عمليات قصف بينهم
فتيه واطفال
شهداء وايضا اكثر من مئه وعشرين جريحا
بينهم اكثر من عشرين حاله وصلت بالخطيره
وتم نقل العشرات من هذه الاصابات الى
المستشفيات
المجاوره في المحافظات الفلسطينيه
المجاوره في الضفه الغربيه وذلك لعدم
الخضره للمستشفيات الداخليه في مدينه وفي
مخيم جنين الاستيعاب لهذه الاعداد الكبيره
التي سقطت خلال برصاص الاحتلال خلال هذه
العمليه العسكريه ايضا كان الوضع الانساني
كان
متفاقم بشكل كبير على مستوى
الاهالي التي تم اجبارهم وارغامهم بقصرا
بخروب الخروج من منازلهم وايضا اقتحامات
من الجيش الاحتلال لهذه المنازل وتكسير
الجدران والانتقال من بيت الى بيت عبر هذه
الثغرات التي كان جيش الاحتلال يحدثها في
البيوت وذلك في محاوله للبحث عن المخازن
وايضا ما تدعي قوات الاحتلال بوجود مخازن
الاسلحه
التي جرت العمليه على اساسها وهل من اصداء
لمقتل جندي اسرائيلي اخر كما تقول كتائب
القسام والسرايا القدس وشهداء الاقصى
الخط الناظم في الموقف الاسرائيلي الراهن
هو ما كان نتنياهو قد روج له في ساعات
الظهر وهو وعاد عليه في ساعات المساء وهو
بان هذه العمليه حققت اهدافها حسب رؤيته
لكنها لن تكون الاخيره بمعنى ان قوات
الاحتلال قد تواصل عملياته مهاجمتها لجنين
ومخيمها في قادم الايام على اساس ان الخطه
الاسرائيليه في البدايه كانت تهدف الى
القيام بتوجيه ضربه قويه هم في البدايه
قالوا بانهم يريدون استثاث ما يسمونه
بالارهاب في اشاره المقاومه الفلسطينيه
بعدها ادركوا ان هذا شبه مستحيل ان لم يكن
مستحيل بالكامل فاصبحوا يتحدثون عن ان
الهدف هو ان تتمكن قواتهم في اوقات لاحقه
من القيام بعمليات في قلب جنين ومخيمها
دون
[موسيقى]
ادركوا في ساعات ظهيره هذا اليوم ان عدد
كبير من المقاومين الفلسطينيين قد نجح
بالاختفاء سواء انسحب الى خارج المخيم ام
انه اختفى داخل المخيم فبقيت معاركهم
بالاساس في الاحياء المحيطه في وسط قلب
المخيم تحديدا
حي عبد الله عزام والاحياء الاخرى
المجاوره له لكن حاره الحواشين في وسط
مخيم لم يصلوها
اصطحبوا معهم اليوم طواقم صحفيه اسرائيليه
لكي تروج لما قاموا فيه بالمخيم لكن
تقارير التي وردت من هناك لم تكن من قلب
المخيم بقدر ما كان معظمها من مداخل
المخيم لذلك يبدو انه سيكون هناك جدل في
اسرائيل خاصه وان القياده العسكريه
الامنيه كانت في الصباح
طلبت بان توقف العمليه وتبدا بالسحب
القوات القياده السياسيه رفضت وطالبت ان
يتم تاج ذلك لساعات الليل على امل ان تحقق
انجازات اكثر لاننا نتنياهو كان يبحث عن
صوره انتصار لم يجدها عندما وصل الى
القاعده العسكريه في سالم على المدخل
الغربي لمدينه لمنطقه جنين
وجاء وادلى بتصريحات ثم قفل عائدا هذه
القوات الكبيره التي ادخلوها وايضا تضخيم
الانجاز على انهم عثروا على ترسانه
للاسلحه والذخائر ومصانع للعبوات الناسفه
وما شابه هذا كله يكون لا شيء مقارنه مع
الدمار الذي زرعوه والذي سيبدا يتضح مع
شروق الشمس الدمار والقتل في داخل مخيم
وتدمير البنيه التحتيه هل هذا هو ما بعثت
عنه اسرائيل هذا يشير الى ان قواتها
المؤلله والجراره التي دخلت لم تتمكن من
تحقيق اي من الاهداف سوى اذا اعتبروا ان
القتل هو هدف لان هناك اطفال قتلوا ايضا
من استشهد معظمهم من الفتيه وبتتراوح معهم
بين 17 و 22 عاما لكن مقاتلين معروفين ومن
قوى المقاومه داخل
المخيم جنين هذا لم يترك ثانيا العمليه
التي وقعت في تل ابيب واعلنت حماس
مسؤوليتها عنها اشارت هذه العمليه ايضا
الى هشاشه الوضع الامني الاسرائيلي لانه
في ظل ذروه والجميع مشدود امنيا في
اسرائيل واجراءات امنيه هائله يتمكن شاب
فلسطيني من ان ينفذ ولو كانت عمليه دهز
فهذا مؤشر اخر على هشاشه الوضع لكن هذه
حكومه الصهيونيه الدينيه عقليتها مختلفه
هي لا تفكر
بعقليه واقعيه بقدر ما تفكر بعقليه
الانتقام وعقليه التفرد وعقليه البطش
واستخدام القوه الغاشمه
لتركيع الفلسطينيين ولكن يبدو ان النتيجه
ستاتي معكوسه لدرجه ان هناك من يرى بان
هذه المعركه هذا المخيم الصغير تشبه الى
حد كبير ربما معركه الكرامه عام 1969 الى
ما انتهت اليه ان الكثيرين من الشبان
الفلسطينيين في حينه اندفعوا وتطوعوا
وتجددوا في ثوره الفلسطينيه وهذا ما اجرته
هذا ما وقع الان في جنين قد يعزز من صفوف
المقاومه اكثر من قبل شكرا لك يا وليد
العمرين مدير مكتب الجزيره في رام الله
والشكر موصول لسمير ابو شماله من جنين
والياسه كرام من شمال جنين وبالتحديد من
معبر الجلمه
[موسيقى]
قاعده لوجستيه كبيره لسلاح المدرعات شمال
جنين جهزها الجيش الاسرائيلي لتعزيز
عمليات التواغل نحو مخيم جنين فقوات
الاحتلال استخدمت تعزيزات خلال الساعات
الماضيه لاحكام الحصار التي تطبقه على
المخيم منذ بدء العمليه العسكريه عند
المدخل الشمالي تجوب اليه عسكريه للمكان
بشكل مستمر المدخل الجنوبي في شارع نابلس
بدوره تحت الرصد الكامل عبر الدوريات
اسرائيليه متحركه
اما المدخل الرئيسي فيركز عنده جيش
الاحتلال قواته بوحدات راجله واليه عسكريه
كما نشر قناصه عند اسطح مباني مطله على
المكان وعند المدخل الغربي تتحصن مجموعه
من جيش الاحتلال اما في اذقه المخيم
الداخليه فالوضع الميداني اكثر تعقيدا
اللافت في تطور تحرك المقاومه اعلان كتائب
عز الدين القسام دورها الى جانب الفصائل
الاخرى وتحديدا سرايا القدس في عمليه
التصدي التطور الاهم يدور عند حي عبد الله
عزام القريب من وسط جنين مواجهه داريه
ومستمره فمحاولات جنود الاحتلال التوغل
الى قلب المخيم تواجه بمقاومه شديده يضطر
بسببها الجنود الى التنقل في الحي من داخل
المنازل بتفجير الجدران الفاصله تحاشيا
للوقوع في كمائن المق اومه والاشتباك
المباشر
حاره الدمج الواقعه عند المدخل الجنوبي
والتي تقود الى قلب المخيم ايضا تشهد
اشتباكات عنيفه وتواجه قوات الاحتلال فيها
مقاومه شرسه
يمتاز الحي بازقه ضيقه للغايه ومنازل
متلاصقه تصعب عمل الجيوش النظاميه وتكون
مهمه المقاومين اكثر سهوله
تحاول قوات الاحتلال عبر هذه المنطقه شق
طريقها الى قلب جنين وتتنقل داخل المنازل
هربا من عبوات ناسفه تتحدث معلومات ان
المقاومين زرعوها لعرقله تقدم
الاسرائيليين اما غرب المخيم فالتطورات
فيه اقل حده مقارنه بباقي الاحياء مع
اشتباكات متقطعه
فصائل المقاومه التي تتصدى للعدوان
الاسرائيلي توزع عملها في المخيم بين
وحدات تشتبك مع الجيش الاسرائيلي واخرى
تتولى مهاجمه التجمعات وتتحدث الفصائل عن
وجود وحدات هندسيه تابعه لها تقوم بمهام
رفض ومهاجمه تمركز الاليات والمدرعات
وتعمل اخرى على نشر عبوات ناسفه لمنع
التقدم اما من الجانب الاسرائيلي فتشارك
عده وحدات في حصار جنين منها
وهي وحده متخصصه في العمليات البريه
المعقده في المناطق المغلقه والغابات
والحقول مجلان وهي وحده كومندس متخصصه في
تدمير اهداف في عمق ميدان المعركه يا هلم
او الوحده الهندسيه وتختص في تنفيذ مهام
الاقتحام الهندسيه والهجمات التفجيريه
والتخلص من الالغام وتشغيل الروبوتات
العسكريه لواء نحال وهو لواء مشاه نظامي
شارك في جميع الحروب الاسرائيليه منذ عام
تنفذ مهامها بمشاركه جنود مستعربين عوكت
وهي وحده الكلاب التي تستخدم ضمن مهام
خاصه في الجيش الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو ان العمليه العسكريه في جنين لن
تقتصر على جوله واحده واضاف في ختام تقييم
للموقف الامني بحضور وزير الدفاعه يوافق
في معسكري معبر سالم على شارع حيفا غرب
جنين ان العمليه تقترب من نهايتها بعد ان
حققت اهدافها حسب تعبيره
من يعتقد ان مثل هذه العمليه ستردعنا عن
مواصله معركتنا ضد الارهاب فهو مخطئ وهو
لا يعرف روح دوله اسرائيل ولا يعرف
حكومتنا ولا مواطنين ولا مقاتلين ابارك
لمقاتلين الشجعان الذين دمروا بنا تحتيه
ارهابيه كثيره جدا في جنين ومنعوا بذلك
الكثير من العمليات الارهابيه في هذه
الاثناء نكمل المهمه واقول ان عمليه
الواسعه في جنين لن تقتصر على جوله واحده
سنواصل مهما استغرقت من وقت حتى يتم
اشتثاث الارهاب ولن نسمح لجنين ان تتحول
الى ملجا للارهاب وسنضرب الارهاب في كل
مكان
دانت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه باشد العبارات
ترضى وتهجير عائلات فلسطينيه في مخيم جنين
من منازلها واضافت في بيان ان تهجير
العائلات من جنين يعد جريمه وانتهاكا
صارخا للقانون الدولي الانساني واتفاقيات
جنيف وطلبت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه المجتمع
الدولي ومؤسسات الامم المتحده المختصه
بالتدخل الفوري لحمايه السكان المدنيين
مما سمته بطشه لاحتلال
قال القياديه في حركه حماس اسامه حمدان
للجزيره ان العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
في جنين هي مخطط استراتيجي لافراغ مناطق
بالضفه الغربيه لصالح توسيع الاستيطان
من الواضح ان اهم اهداف العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه هو النيل من المقاومه كسر
ارادتها وكسر اراده الشعب الفلسطيني في
مخيم جنينك حاضنه لهذه المقاومه لكن ايضا
ما يجب ان يلحظ هنا ان هذه العمليه تهدف
الى توسيع دائره الاستيطان وحمايه
الاستيطان التهجير الذي قامت به قوات
الاحتلال يوم امس لقراب الثلاثه الاف
فلسطيني من ابناء المخيم ليس بريئا ولا
يمكن الحديث عنه على انه جزء من عمليه
عسكريه مجرده بقدر ما هو مخطط استراتيجي
من اجل البدء في عمليه افراغ مناطق في
الضفه لصالح توسيع الاستيطان
وفي تل ابيب اصيب سبعه اشخاص بعمليه تهس
وطعن نفذها شاب فلسطيني وافاد شهود عيان
ان منفذ العمليه كان يقود سياره بسرعه
فائقه واصطدم بقوه بمحطه لتوقف الحافلات
وبعدها ترجل وقام بطعن اسرائيليين قبل ان
يقوم حارس امن باطلاق النار عليه من قريبه
وقد اظهر مقطع فيديو ان منفذ العمليه كان
يرتدي بنطالا عسكريا وقامت قوات الشرطه
الاسرائيليه بتطويق مسرح العمليه وتمشيط
المنطقه هذا وتبنت حركه حماس عمليه تل
ابيب ونعت منفذها عبد الوهاب خلايله واكدت
ان هذه العمليه هي بدايه الرد على عدوان
الاحتلال على جنين
ومن موقع عمليه تل ابيب دع وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي اعتماد جميع
الاسرائيليين الى حمل السلاح حسبما نقلت
صحيفه معاريف وقال بنكفير الذي زار موقع
العمليه انه هجوم انه هجومه تل ابيب يثبت
مره اخرى اهميه وفعاليه المواطنين الذين
يحملون السلاح ونقلت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه
هتافات من جانب اسرائيليين طلبوه بتوفير
الامن بينما وصفه بعضهم بالعنصريه
الارهابي
ينضموا الينا من رام الله ساري عرابي
الكاتب والباحث السياسي سيد ساري حركه
حماس وصفت العمليه التي جرت في تل ابيب
بانهايه الرد على ما جرى في مخيم جنين ما
هي المحددات التي تدفع بفصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه الى تحريك ساحات مختلفه لدعم
ساحه معينه
يعني اولا اعتقد ان هناك حاله مقاومه اخذه
بالتكرس والتجذر في ساحه الضفه الغربيه
بالرغم من اجراءات الاحتلال الواسعه مثل
عمليه كاسر الامواج التي دفع بها الى قلب
الضفه الغربيه وهذه العمليه واضحه انها
فشلت تماما في تطبيق واستيعاب وتفكيك حاله
المقاومه في الضفه الغربيه او العمليه
الاخيره الواسعه التي شنها على مخيم جنين
والتي سماها البيت والحديقه ومن ثم فنحن
بالفعل حاله مقاومه ومشهديه مقاومه موجوده
بطبيعه الحال تاخذ اشكالا متعدده ومتنوعه
مثل سلسله الهبات التي كانت موجوده في
الضفه الغربيه وكل هبه تسلم نفسها الى هبه
اخرى في اعوام 2014 2015 2017
2019-2021 حتى وصلنا الى هذا الشكل الحالي
وهذه حاله المقاومه تاخذ اشكالا متعدده
مره اخرى يعني ما بين عمليات ذات طابع
فردي وما بين عمليات تدفع بها التنظيمات
الفلسطينيه وما بين تشكيلات مسلحه كما هو
موجود الان في مخيم جنين وفي مناطق اخرى
في شماليه ضبط الغربيه فانا اعتقد اساس
تنفيذ هذا النوع من العمليات التي تدفع
بها فصائل المقاومه او التي يقوم بها
شبانيا لبعض فصائل المقاومه هي تاتي في
هذا السياق الطويل انا اعتقد ان الفصائل
المقاومه منذ فتره طويله ولا سيما بعد
سلسله الحروب التي خططتها المقاومه في
قطاع غزه كانت الحريصه للغايه على تفعيل
الساحه الاهم في مواجهه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وهي ساحه الضفه الغربيه التي
يعتبرها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حديقته التي
يتمدد اليها استطانيا وهي الساحه التي
يتعامل معها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
باعتبارها ساحه الايديولوجيا والدعايه
الصهيونيه بالدرجه الاولى ويعتبرها العمق
الاستراتيجي انا اعتقد ان المقاومه منذ
فتره طويله كانت حريصه على وجود ساحات
اخرى تدعم وتعزز حاله المقاومه الموجوده
في قطاع غزه في هذا السياق كله ياتي هذا
النوع من العمليات علينا ان نتذكر العمليه
التي نفذها مقاتلان واستشهداء من كتاب
القسام عمليه عريض قرب مستوطنات عليه قبل
فتره وجيزه وهكذا في كل هذا السياق تاتي
هذه العمليه طيب سيد سالي يعني نتنياهو
يقول بان عمليه جنين لن تقتصر على جوله
واحده ما يؤشر الى ان المعتمد من الان
فصاعد هو مجموعه عمليات تجريبي وتيره
متصاعده يقوم بها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بتقدير كيف يمكن ان تتعاطى او كيف ستتعاطى
وتستعد المقاومه الفلسطينيه لوتيره اكثر
ارتفاعا في المرحله المقبله من العمليات
والاقتحامات
يعني الحقيقه هناك جمله نقاط لابد من
التاكيد عليها في سياق الحديث عن هذا
الموضوع اول هذه النقاط ما سبق وتحدثنا
عنه قبل قليل اصلا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يدفع باكثر من 25 كتيبه داخل ساحه الضفه
الغربيه وهناك عمليه كاس الامواج اصلا هي
موجوده ومستمره في ساحه الضفه الغربيه
الاجراءات الواسعه التي يسميها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالاجراءات الواسعه اصلا كانت
سابقه لعمليه اقتحام مخيم جنين كما نتذكر
مثل حصار مدينه نابلس مثل حصار مدينه
اريحا كذلك الاقتحامات الدمويه لنابلس
ولمخيم جنين على وجه التحديد والتي كان
يرتقي فيها في اليوم الواحد اكثر من عشره
شهداء ومن ثم هذه العمليه التي دفع بها
نحو مخيم جنين لا شك انها عمليه الاكثر
عنفا والاكثر دمويه والاكثر بطشا واستخدم
فيها القوات مدججه وحاشده ونخب وفرق
متعدده ووحدات متعدده من جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالاضافه لاستخدامه لسلاح الجو
لا شك ان هذه العمليه كانت مختلفه من حيث
هذه الحيثيه بالاضافه لقوه النيران والقصف
والتدمير ولكنها في الحقيقه تاتي في هذا
السياق يعني بمعنى ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
كلما راى نفسه مازوما من الناحيه الامنيه
وكلما راى ان حاله المقاومه في ساحه الضفه
الغربيه لا يستطيع ان يتعامل معها فقط
بالاجراءات الموضعيه
العلاجات الموضعيه في هذه المنطقه او تلك
المنطقه هو يضطر لتوسيع هذا النوع من
العمليات وهذا التوسيع اصلا يتعارض مع
سياسه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تجاه الضفه
الغربيه يعني بمعنى ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يسعى منذ فتره طويله لهندسه
الجماهير الضفه الغربيه لخلق بنيه
اقتصاديه وعلاقات اقتصاديه ما يغرق بها
الجماهير في الضفه الغربيه بحيث يحيد هذه
الجماهير عن القيام بواجبها النضالي
والكفاحي في مواجهه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
باليمين نتنياهو نفسه يتبنى سيارته يسميها
السلام الاقتصادي سلف بن يمين نتنياهو بنت
كان يتبني سياسه يسميها تقليص الصراع كل
هذه السياسات هدفها الابقاء على الاحتلال
كما هو ابقاء ساحه الضفه الغربيه ساحه
حيويه للاحتلال الاسرائيلي مع ضمان الهدوء
في ساحه هذه الضفه الغربيه ومن ثم حاله
المقاومه التي كانت موجوده في مخيم جرين
القت هذا الث الكبير من التحدي على
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حتى اضطر الى توسيع
عملياته على النحو الذي نرى الان نعم تفضل
طيب السيد سالي ولكن دائما ما كانت هنالك
خشيه لدى الجانب الاسرائيلي من ان تقوم اي
عمليه
بتفجير الساحات المختلفه شمال لبنان عفوا
جنوب لبنان او حتى
الضفه الغربيه قطاع غزه ولكن فيما جرى في
العمليتين الاخيرتين سواء قطاع غزه او ما
جرى في جنين لم نرى بان هذه الساحات تحركت
كيف يمكن ان نقرا هذا المعطى
الحقيقه هذا سؤال مهم هو بطبيعه الحال
مطروح حتى على المستوى الفلسطيني ولكن كي
نفهم طبيعه المشهد المعقد في الحاله
الفلسطينيه ينبغي ان ندرك ان هناك ظروف
متباينه للغايه بين مختلف مواقع
الفلسطينيين حتى في ساحه الضفه الغربيه
منذ نهايه انتفاضه الاقصى والاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يفرض سياسات عزل وفصل وضبط
وسيطره بحيث يعزل كل منطقه فلسطينيه عن
المنطقه الاخرى ويوجد ظروف متباينه ومصالح
مختلفه ما بين كل منطقه واخرى ولذلك كما
سلف وقلنا اشكال المقاومه والنضال تختلف
ما بين مناطق الضفه الغربيه المتعدده
الامر نفسه في الحقيقه فيما يتعلق بقطاع
غزه يعني قطاع غزه خاضا سلسله مواجهات
كبيره فضلا عن الحروب الضخمه في 2008 2009
و2012 و2014 ثم 2021 22 23 طبيعه الحال
هذا يلقي اعباء مختلفه ومتفاوته ما بين
منطقه واخرى ويعقد الحسابات ما بين منطقه
واخرى يعني بمعنى الظروف الفلسطينيه على
المستوى الامني واللوجستي والسياسي
والعسكري والامني والاقتصادي داخل قطاع
غزه مخت تماما عما هي عليه داخل ساحه
الضفه الغربيه ومن ثم المقاومه في قطاع
غزه تذهب الى سياسه المراكمه وتطوير
القدرات وتطوير الخبرات
والمعرفه النقاط القوه ونقاط الضعف وترميم
الجراحه استعدادا لمعارك اكبر ومعارك اهم
مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في حين انها تسعى
اي المقاومه في قطاع غزه بمختلف قواها
وفصائلها الى تعزيز ساحه الضفه الغربيه
وخلق نقاط مقاومه جديده في ساحه الضفه
الغربيه تحمل كتفا مع المقاومه داخل قطاع
غزه في سياق هذه الحسابات المعقده قد
تتدخل هذه الساحه او لا تتدخل هذه الساحه
لكن علينا ان ندرك بطبيعه الحال انه قد لا
يكون من الصواب ان تدخل ساحه محاصره وضيقه
ومكشوفه في حرب كل عام يعني نحن نتحدث عن
2022-2023 قطاع غزه يعني خاض حروبا طاحنه
مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انا اعتقد ان هذه
حسابات معقده تدفع المقاومه داخل قطاع غزه
لاعطاء فرصه للمقاومه داخل ساحه الضفه
الغربيه لتطوير والحقيقه المشهد الذي
رايناه في مخيم جنين هو ينوم عن صوابي هذه
الرؤيه يعني
قال الناطق باسم الرئاسه الفلسطينيه نبيل
ابو ردينه للجزيره ان الجانب الفلسطيني
قطع جميع الاتصالات مع اسرائيل واضاف ان
عمليه جنين ترمي لتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه
الاهداف الحقيقيه هي تصفيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه وفتح الباب امام مشاريع وهميه
ولعلك تذكر ان هنالك مؤامره كانت اسمها
دوله ذات حدود مؤقته تتنازل عن القدس
بهدنه لمده 30 عاما ورفضها الشعب
الفلسطيني ثم جاءت مؤامره اخرى هو توسيع
قطاع غزه في النقب وفي سيناء واقامه اماره
في غزه واحبط الشعب الفلسطيني هذه
المؤامره الدوله الفلسطينيه قائمه على
الارض الدوله الفلسطينيه لها لها قواعد
وقوانين وثوابت وطنيه ورغم كل العدوان
الاسرائيلي وكل المحاولات الامريكيه
لتركيع الشعب الفلسطيني الشعب الفلسطيني
لن يستسلم
ينضم الينا من القدس اسماعيل مسلماني
المحلل السياسي المختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي سيد اسماعيل
ما تقييمكم لما حققته هذه العمليه من
اهداف وما قدره نتنياهو على تسويقها في
الداخل
الاسرائيلي وهو بدا بالخروج من مخيم جنين
او قواته على الاقل نعم واضح بعد مرور
اربعين ساعه تقريبا علما بان المؤسسه
الامنيه او العسكريه لم تعلن بشكل تاكيد
رسمي بامتحابها من مخيم جنين طبعا هذا
لاسباب كثيره لانها لا تريد ان تظهر بان
هناك انتصارا لهذا المخيم في نهايه الامر
الاهداف لم تضعها بشكل معلن ورسمي نتيجه
الدروس السابقه التي تعلمتها في تجربه مع
الجبهه اللبنانيه خاصه في عام 2005 و206
لان الاعلان عن الاهداف سبب ارباكا كبيرا
بلجان التحقيق وحاله النفسيه للجيش
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي اليوم
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بقياده نتنياهو لا
يعلن عن الاهداف لكن من خلال المعطيات ومن
خلال المصادر الاسرائيليه والعبريه كانت
واضحه ان هذه العمليه وهي وضعت قبل اعيد
الاضحى المبارك بايام عديده هي عمليه
محدده
واسعه النطاق بمعنى استخدام القوه المفرطه
واعطاء رسائل اولا كانت هذه من ضمن
الاهداف هو ترهيب الشعب الفلسطيني وتحديدا
الحاضنه الشعبيه في المخيم ومحيط مخيم
جنين بالاضافه الى المدن الفلسطينيه
استخدام هذه القوه المفرطه مع النخب
العسكريه المختلفه من كافه الكتائب
الاسرائيليه والتي اظهرت بان هناك فشلا
واضحا باتجاه يجري وسط ما قبل ساعات
الاعنق المواجهه وكانت تراهن في خلال 24
ساعه من خلال يعني الجانب الاسرائيلي تحدث
عن ان اهداف العمليه القضاء على الارهاب
القضاء على البنيه
العسكريه لما يسميه
بالارهاب انت تقول بان اهداف هذه العمليه
لم تكن واضحه وذلك باخذ بالعبر للعمليات
السابقه كيف يمكن ان يسوق نتنياهو لهذه
العمليه بانها نجحت اذا في الداخل
الاسرائيلي
نعم هذا نعم وهذا السؤال في محله حتى لا
يتعرض نتنياهو للاحراج الكبير وخاصه الان
نحن نشاهد ان الانتحاب تدريجي بمعنى بدون
الاعلان برسم عدد بدليل ان بعض المسؤولين
مثل الاركان الاسرائيلي وبعد مسؤولين
قالوا باننا سوف ندخل في اي جهه وسوف ندخل
في اي وقت وان هذه الجوله لن تنتهي مره
اخرى وسوف نعود مره اخرى هذا يعني بان
نتنياهو يريد ان يحفظ وجهه او وجه الماء
من نتيجه الان ردود الفعل وبدات الاصوات
في داخل المعارضه الاسرائيليه تعلى
بالجانب وخاصه بدا المشهد الفلسطيني في
المدن الفلسطينيه حاله الغليان وبدات
الكره تتدحرج الى انتفاضه ثالثه هو الان
يريد اعطاء درس للمخيم واعطاء درس لمحيط
المخيم بان القوه المفرطه
سلاح الجو الذي استخدمه ما شاهدناه اليوم
في خلال الاربعون ساعه لم تشهده القضيه
الفلسطينيه منذ حتى عام 48 بالتي ارتكبت
بالنقبه حتى وصف مصطلح النكبه هو الان لا
يكفي للتعبير عما جرى في داخل المخيم
دعينا نقول على سبيل المثال ما استخدم
الان طبق في الحرب العالميه الاولى او
الثانيه تماما قطع المياه وقطع الكهرباء
فصل مخيم جنين عن القرى المحيطه وضع
السواتر دخول القذائف واستخدام سلاح الجو
هو تطبيق فعلي
لوحشيه عن جهيه هذه الحكومه بمرور تسعه
شهور تقريبا من فعله نتنياهو هي مغامره
غير محسوبه بمعنى هو يريد
ساحه غزه وساحه اللبنانيه والساحه السوريه
وكافه الساحات وعلى راسها
ايران وبالتالي من هنا بدات هذه العمليه
الموسعه لاعتقاده لكن عنصر المفاجاه نعم
شكرا لك عذرا على المقاطعه اسماعيل
مسلماني المحلل السياسي المختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي كنت معنا من القدس
في تفاصيل اليوم الثاني من العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في جنين كان مشهد
الاوضاع الانسانيه مترديا فقوه الاحتلال
تواجه اتهامات بتهجير الاف من سكانها اما
من كانوا محاصرين داخل جنين فوجهوا نقصا
في المواد الغذائيه وانقطاعا للخدمات
تستحضر هذه الصور لسكان مخيم جنين مشاهد
الاباء والاجداد زمن النكبه الفلسطينيه
عام 48 اخرج هؤلاء من بيوتهم عنوه على يدي
جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي خلال عمليته
العسكريه على المخيم للكثافه الاكبر من
بين مخيمات الضفه الغربيه فاصبح اللاجئون
مهجرين مره اخرى استنادا الى رئيس بلديه
جنين فان مجموعه ما هجره الجيش الاسرائيلي
بلغ حتى الان نحو 4000 فلسطيني وانه يحاصر
قرابه ثلاثه عشر الفا داخل المخيم ثم شرع
الجيش الاسرائيلي بتجريف المنازل او
تخريبها او تحويلها لمقر عسكريه مؤقته كما
حول بعضها الى نقاط عبور لجنوده عبر فتح
ثغرات في الجدران بهدف تنقلهم من منطقه
لاخرى والوصول الى قلب المخيم حيث يتحصل
مقاومون فلسطينيون هناك اما من بقي من
سكان مخيم جنين فليسوا بافضل حالا فهذه
البقعه الصغيره المكتظه بالسكان شهدت كل
اشكال الحرب و شبكه الكهرباء والمياه وفق
المنسقات الامميه للشؤون الانسانيه وعلاوه
على ذلك منعت الطواقيم الطبيه من الوصول
الى من يحتاجها واعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه اعتقل نحو 120 شخصا
تعلن وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه بدا انسحاب
الجيش الاسرائيلي من المخيم وكان رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامينه نياهو قال ان
الاقتحام او الهجوم سيتكرر ما دام ذلك
ضروريا للقضاء على ما يصفه بالارهاب وان
جنين لن تعود مجال له
لكن ما حدث في المخيم من تهجير وهدم
لمنازل المدنيين يثير اسئله تشير الى نقطه
ابعد من الوقوف عند عمليه عسكريه امنيه
فنتنياهو نفسه وقبل ايام صرح بالضروره
العمل على اجتثاث فكره اقامه الدوله
الفلسطينيه يضاف الى ذلك ما اقرته الحكومه
الاسرائيليه مؤخرا من تسهيل اجراءات
التوسع الاستيطاني في كل ارجاء الضفه
الغربيه
وفي مقابله هاتفيه مع الجزيره تحدثت
المواطنه الفلسطينيه تهاني جمال وهي احدى
من اجبروا على الخروج من منزلها في جنين
عن مداهمه القوات الاسرائيليه لمنزلها
والمنازل المجاوره واجبارها واسرتها عن
الخروج من المنزل بعد اطلاق النار على
ابنها
مباشره على البيوت
على البيوت حاولوا يدخلوا على البيوت من
بيت لبيت
انهم يفتحوا فتحات في البيوت حتى ما وصلوا
بيتنا وكل بيت يفوت عليه ليش انتم بعدكم
مش طالعين من البيوت احنا بلغنا فيه
اجتياح حكينا لهم انه احنا هاي بيوتنا
اخذوا ابنه وطلعوها على بيت الجيران على
من بيت لبيت مكلفه انك تطلع الطريق هاي
امشيها انا اطلع من البيت على اساس انه
خلوه مفتاح
ايمان طرابلسي المتحدثه الاقليميه بسم
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر سيده ايمان
ما الذي سجله صليب الاحمر من انتهاكات في
هذه العمليه التي قامت بها القوات
الاسرائيليه في جنين
للاسف ما نلاحظه ميدانيا هو ان
العمليه التي التي تدور على المستوى اليوم
الثاني على التوالي اليوم هي تؤثر بشكل
مباشر على المدنيين وتؤدي الى تدهور مستمر
للوضعيه للوضع الانساني في جنين ما نشهده
ميدانيا هو هو ضرر الحق بمصالح وحياه
وسلامه المدنيين تهجير حركه تهجير من وراء
عمليات العنف وحاله رعب في صفوف المدنيين
سواء اولئك الذين اضطروا الى ترك منازلهم
واللجوء الى اماكن اكثر امنا او اولئك
الذين لا يزالون داخل المناطق التي التي
شملتها العمليه بدون
القدره على
الوصول الى ابسط الامدادات بما ان العمليه
ادت الى ضرر بالبناء تحتيه الاساسيه
لاسيما لاسيما بني التحتيه الخاصه بالمياه
والكهرباء وكذلك قدره اثرت على قدره
السكان لبلوغ
الخدمات الصحيه اليوم
حاليا يعني هل يعتبر ذلك انتهاكا للقانون
الدولي الانساني
نحن نعيد نداءاتنا سواء كان ذلك على
الفضاء العام او في محادثاتنا الثنائيه مع
كل الاطراف بان استعمال مظاهر استعمال
القوه والاستخدام القوه يجب ان
تتفق مع ما تمليه قواعد القوانين قواعد
القانون الدولي الانساني ومعاييره حمايه
حياه المدنيين ومصالحهم هو خط احمر غير
قابل الى غير قابل للجدال اليوم نعيد
نداءنا لكل الاطراف بان يجب اتخاذ كل
التدابير اللازمه لحمايه حياه ومصالح
المدنيين وكذلك حمايه قدرتهم على البلوغ
الى الخدمات الاساسيه وحمايه البنيه
التحتيه الاساسيه
اللازمه لهم حاليا كذلك هناك تحدي كبير في
مستوى قدره السكان الى بلوغ خاصه
ما يحتاجون من الخدمات الصحيه وهنا اعيد
ونعيد ندائنا في الفضاء العام كذلك بان
هناك وجوب حمايه الحيز المخصص لعمليات
الاغاثه وتوفير ظروف الظروف اللازمه لعمال
الاغاثه في سبيل تاديه
عملهم بامان سيده ايمان في اي خانه من
الانتهاكات تضعون استهداف تواقم الاسعاف
وسيارات الاسعاف التي تسعى لنقل الجرحى
لست مخوله لكي لكي اقوم بهذا بهذا النوع
من التصنيف سيدتي ولكن اعيدني دائما باننا
باننا في محادثاتنا الثنائيه وكذلك في
نداءنا العام نعيد الحث على ضروره احترام
مصالح واتخاذ كل تدابير الاحترام مصالح
وحياه المدنيين وكذلك حمايه الحيث المخصص
لعمليات الاغاثه ان هذه العمليه جعلت
الوضع في مخيم جنين صعب كما وصفتيه ولكن
كيف كان عليه في الاشهر السابقه وهو هذا
ليس الاقتحام الاول
للمخيم قد يكون الاقوى والاعنف
بالفعل سيدتي يعني سكان جنين وسكان
العديد من المناطق في الضفه الغربيه وهم
يعيشون على وقع وتر
متواصل لعمليات العنف على امتداد السته
الاشهر الاولى لهذه السنه
ادى الى تدهور الوضعيه الانسانيه بالفعل
يعني العمليه التي تقوم التي التي تحصل
حاليا هي تقع على خلفيه
سلسله من التصعيدات سلسله من من مظاهر
العنف التي عانى منها السكان ولا يزالون
يعانون منها حاليا اليوم هناك ضروره قصوى
لاتخاذ تدابير سريعه وعاجله لضمان يعني
لضمان حمايه المدنيين حاليا لايقاف دائره
العنف المستمر
شكرا للاسف نريد كمان
اريد فقط الاضافه نقطه مهمه جدا واننا
كفاعل انساني محايد ليست لدينا سلطه لفرض
هذه
التدابير او للعمل على تنفيذها بما ان هذه
المسؤوليه تقع على عاتق السلطات المعنيه
بالاساس نحن منظمه انسانيه وبالتالي لا
يمكننا حمايه المدنيين بشكل مباشر من
تعرضهم الى العنف شكرا
لجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
هذه الصور كانت قد جاءتنا قبل قليل من
جنين ويبدو بان اهالي جنين يحتفلون ببدا
خروج قوات الاحتلال وارتاله من جنين اذا
نحن نشاهد اهالي الجنين وهم يحتفلون في
هذه الصور وكانت قوات الاحتلال قد بدات قد
بدات منذ ساعتين بالخروج بشكل كبير وكثيف
من مخيم الجنين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا بعض هتفاته اهالي جنين استمعنا اليها
من خلال هذه الصور وفي خدم قلق دولي رافقه
لعمليه الاسرائيليه في جنين دعت لندن تل
ابيب الى حمايه المدنيين وتراجع عن سياسه
الاستيطان في حين اكدت برلين اهميه الحل
السياسي وشددت على سلامه العاملين بالمجال
الانساني اما الامم المتحده فطالبت بوقف
القتل وتدمير الممتلكات في جنينه هذا
ويعقد مجلس الامن الدولي يوم الجمعه جلسه
مشاورات مغلقه بشان الاوضاع في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
تقدم
فتراجع يبدو بنيامين نتنياهو الاحرس بين
شركاء حكومته على الا تطول عمليه اقتحام
جنين اكثر من اللازم انه اللازم على
الارجح لتحقيق اهداف ليست امنيه خالصه
صحيح ان عمليه الاقتحام العسكري الاوسع
لجنين منذ الانتفاضه الثانيه تاتي في ظل
استمرار تحريض اليمين الاسرائيلي المتطرف
عليها مدينه ومخيما ومقاومه لكن وبحسابات
اسرائيليه داخليه يصعب اغفال ان العمليه
تتزامن مع تصاعد حده الاحتجاجات ضد سياسات
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو الائتلافيه
رسميا وبعيدا عن مسعى نتنياهو لرفع منسوب
شعبيته وطمانه شركائه في الحكومه ما زال
شاشه وقاده امنيون في اسرائيل يبررون
اقتحام جنين باستهداف مسلحين فلسطينيين
وتسمع منهم حرصا على تاكيد ان العمليه لا
تستهدف السلطه الفلسطينيه على الاطلاق
والسلطه التي تدين ما يحدث في جنين تطالب
خارجيتها بتدخل الدولي عاجل لوقف عمليه
تهجير عائلات فلسطينيه في مخيم جنين من
منازلها وهو ما يعد جريمه وانتهاكا صارخا
للقانون الدولي الانساني واتفاقيات جنيف
في خضام محنه جنين تنتبه حركه حماس من
جانبها الى ما تقول انه مخطط استراتيجي
لافراغ مناطق بالضفه الغربيه لصالح توسيع
الاستيطان
من الواضح ان اهم اهداف العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه هو النيل من المقاومه كسر
ارادتها وكسر اراده الشعب الفلسطيني في
مخيم جنينك حاضنه لهذه المقاومه لكن ايضا
ما يجب ان يلحظ هنا ان هذه العمليه تهدف
الى توسيع دائره الاستيطان وحمايه
الاستيطان التهجير الذي قامت به قوات
الاحتلال يوم امس لقرابه ثلاثه الاف
فلسطيني من ابناء المخيم ليس بريئا ولا
يمكن الحديث عنه على انه جزء من عمليه
عسكريه مجرده بقدر ما هو مخطط استراتيجي
من اجل البدء في عمليه افراغ مناطق في
الضفه لصالح توسيع الاستيطان
تتلاحق الادانات الاقتحام جنين الاحداث
ذاك الذي توافق الاردن وتركيا على شجبه
بقوه نحن
متفقان على ادانه هذا العدوان وعلى رفضه
تاجيجا وتصعيدا كبيرا في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله ونطالب بوقفه فورا
وندعو المجتمع الدولي للتحرك بشكل فعيل
سريع وفاعل لوقف هذا العدوان الذي لم يؤدي
الا الى المزيد من
العنف والتوتر الذي سينعكس على المنطقه
برمتها
ايران تفضل تسميه ما تكابده جنين اليوم
جريمه تعيد الى الاذهان جرائم النكبه عام
48 من القرن الماضي
قد لا يستخدم المجتمع الدولي العبارات
ذاتها لكنه لا يفتا يعبر عن قلق يتسع من
تداعيات العمليه الاسرائيليه في جنين لندن
دعت تل ابيب الى حمايه المدنيين والتراجع
عن سياسه الاستيطان لانها كما تضيف تشكل
عقبه في طريق السلام
برلين من جانبها اكدت اهميه الحل السياسي
وشددت على سلامه العاملين بالمجال
الانساني
اما الامم المتحده المنزعجه كما تقول من
نطاق العمليه العسكريه في جنين فتطالب
بوقف القتل وتدمير الممتلكات
تنضم الينا من واشنطن
مديره مشروع العولمه الجديده في معهد
الدراسات السياسيه ومؤلفه كتاب فهم الصراع
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيلي سيده فلس يعني موقف
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لطالما كان
يدعو الى ضبط النفس للحفاظ على الوضع
الراهن هل ترين بان توسع الاستيطان
وعمليه جنين والعمليات التي تجري بحق
الفلسطينيين يمكن ان يحافظ على اي وضع
داخل الاراضي الفلسطينيه او في العلاقه مع
اسرائيل
نراه الان هو تصعيد واضح المعالم من قبل
اسرائيل ان نظام الفصل العنصري يتوسع بحيث
المستوطنات تتوسع بالاضافه الى جر في
البيوت والاراضي الفلسطينيه وقتل
الفلسطينيين كل ذلك عباره عن تصعيد كبير
وهذا ليس بالامر الجديد نحن نتحدث عن
حكومه اقصى اليمين المتطرف هي في السلطه
في اسرائيل وهي تتمتع بالافلات من العقاب
بحمايه من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكي
تتفلت من تنفيذ
القوانين الدوليه بالاضافه الى ذلك
الولايات المتحده تقدم الدعم المالي
لاسرائيل والدعم العسكري والاسلحه
لاسرائيل كل ذلك ليس فقط خرقا للقوانين
الدوليه عند استخدام الاسلحه ضد المدنيين
ولكن ايضا هو خرق
قوانين في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولذلك ان اداره بايدن وببساطه تتجاهل
التزام الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بان
حقوق الانسان هي في صلب السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه لاضافه الى ذلك نرى ان البيت
الابيض ومعظم الكونغرس وليس الجميع هو
منفصل عن الشعب الامريكي وعن الناخبين
الامريكيين حيث ان الديمقراطيين اثبتوا
منذ اشهر ان 44% من الناخبين الديمقراطيين
الذين لديهم راي بشان اسرائيل يرون ان ذلك
اصلا عنصريا وهذا التحول كبير ومن الواضح
ان البيت الابيض لا ياخذ ذلك بالحسبان
وبعين الاعتبار وفي مرحله معينه سوف يدفع
ثمنا سياسيا لهذا الانفصال عن الناخبين
في دقيقه واحده ما تداعيات ذلك على مستقبل
الصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي وحل الدولتين
اعتقد ان
الاجابه عن النقطه الثانيه بنسبه الى حل
الدولتين لقد مضى الزمن عليها لانه ما من
ارض باقيه لكي تقوم دوله فلسطينيه مستقله
قابله للحياه وهذه المشكله معروفه من قبل
الفلسطينيين وداعمي الفلسطينيين في كل
انحاء العالم المساله ليست مرتبطه بالدوله
بل بحقوق الفلسطينيين العداله امام
القانون الدولي هذه هي الاعتبارات
سيده فليست بنات مديره مشروع العولمه
الجديده في معهد الدراسات السياسيه
نهايه الحص